committee I also chair the low-grade
Timber commission I got put on that
commission last year I'm still working
because my spouse won't let me retire
yet I'm a full-time real estate attorney
in mass and New Hampshire and I have two
other lives I also am a professional
karate instructor and a coach
International coach and I'm an
equestrian so that rounds me out a
Mr chair um I'm Suzanne Vale and I come
from Nashua this is my fourth term I am
working on my third committee this is my
second term in resources
so my first was in Municipal and County
government and my second in
Transportation so my connection with the
legislation has been in the three
committees that mean the most to me
although I didn't I always ask for
resources so I finally got the committee
and I needed
um I work in the behavioral health field
for 30 years and as of right now I am
retired and I am serving
um and my other life I hike and spend a
lot of time with family
um and I look forward to hearing about
okay
good morning my name is Linda Ryan and
I'm from Nashua this is my first trip
um be kind and I am retired Human
Services worker after 20 years I was in
human services and then for 20 years I
was a science teacher so now I look
forward to what the next 20 years will
good morning my name is Jim Horgan I'm
out of Farmington
this is my third term with the resources
Recreation and development
this is the best committee
uh
I retired from the Navy after 22 years
and went to Farmington and this is a
part of my moral obligation to take care
of my community
after 26 years of doing the various
boards and committees and
trustee positions in the town I thought
it was time to move on
good morning I'm Peter Lovett I
represent Grafton District 8 Plymouth
holderness Ashland
I'm very much a newbie
um I thought we began at 9 30. that's
how new I am
but it's good to be here and and uh
receiving a fire hose of support and
information
good good morning thank you thank you Mr
chairman I'm Tim mcgu from Merrimack
like Representatives Healy and rung my
third term in the house after a little
bit of a layoff my first term on
resources after uh four years on
Commerce I'm really excited to be on
resources and learn a lot about this
committee and thank you to Heather for
the Fantastic support really excited to
have things like the schedules and the
grids that we never had in in Commerce
so this is a real treat to have this
kind of support Mr chairman
uh thing well Heather thanks you but
unfortunately she's leaving at the end
of the month oh well thanks thanks for
preparing us this is a real treatment
nothing we've never had in in Commerce
with 70 70 80 90 bills but a little bit
about me I'm Chief commercial officer
for uh publicly held Med device company
but as far as resources I'm a lifelong
sailor I have a 42-foot vessel and uh 20
plus year scuba diver so I bring a bit
of marine knowledge uh from the lakes of
northern Jersey to the ocean Crossings
and whatnot so my interest is in the
Marine habitat uh and the Marine issues
and of course from Merrimack like
representative Healy and rung those
issues that I'm sure you've all seen in
the news
and representative Healy and wrong have
far superior knowledge to myself but we
all have an interest in our in our
district which is Merrimack Hillsborough
County 12.
thanks
hello I'm Jessica LaMontagne from Dover
semi-retired from um home construction
that business but my other career I was
a public health nutritionist for 20
years
and um I'm from Massachusetts
and lived in North Carolina for 10 years
where I had a family farm
and I'm very glad to be back in New
England
um
I'm very excited to be on this committee
um Ron Dunn from Londonderry it's my
first term I work a full-time job as I'm
passionate about
being involved in government so I make
that work
foreign
my name is Will Darby I'm from Nashua
um in my other life I'm a software
engineer software manager we have uh six
uh grown daughters
um mostly outside of New Hampshire at
this point
I have a camp on Lake down in in Rindge
right on the mass border have been grew
up on Lake Champlain so water is super
important to me
uh let's see
um also Arden Outdoorsman um big bow
hello my name is Tanya Donnelly I am a
first term rep from Salem and I uh grew
up in Upstate New York on Lake George
very close to Lake Champlain I also live
on Canopy Lake and I'm also the Canobie
Lake protective Association president
for that or uh organization so water is
very much a passion of mine I also am a
independent consultant so I still have
to do work
um I'm not I'm semi-retired
um I do business process re-engineering
for digital transformation inside
organizations
um and my passions are skiing boating
all the fun things that you can do
outside as much as possible thank you
yeah I got here right on time hi I'm
Rosemarie wrong I'm in my third term
with the house I'm from Merrimack New
Hampshire I Have A Summer Place in
moultonborough on lake kanasaka so a lot
of issues that come before this
committee are of interest to me I have a
degree in Biochemistry from UNH I had a
career before retirement and analytical
chemistry and public affairs working on
sustainability issues globally I served
on this committee my first term and then
last year I was on Municipal and County
government so I think it's uh it's nice
to be able to bring perspectives from
different committees
and as far as pastimes I like to read I
make beaded jewelry uh I like to snow
ski glad we're getting finally getting
some snow in New Hampshire
I'm Dan Wolf I'm beginning my fourth
term in the legislature did two terms on
the education committee one time on Fish
and Game and
finally got to where I wanted to be so
thank you
um I've lived in Newbury for uh 35
almost 60 years Newbury or Sunapee
family's been in that area since the
late 30s so I'm very familiar with
Western New Hampshire and uh
the importance of recreation and
controlling development to the life of
our state I've got a daughter who works
for the family search and rescue so we
know about getting out early in the
morning late at night Etc keeping our
Woods safe and open
and um I just look forward to
maintaining what New Hampshire really is
the Open Spaces
the
clean air and the water especially on
the Lakes they are really threatened so
I'm looking forward to working with you
I'm Heather Baldwin I represent Grafton
4 which is Thornton Waterville and
Ellsworth
I've lived in the Thornton for 50 years
my husband and I live on a 60 Acre Farm
boarded by National Forest on three
sides we've raised eight children now
have 17 grandchildren and two
great-grandchildren with one on the way
all of us are Avid skiers hikers
um
my background educationally
I have a degree in a biology chemistry
and Marine Science I did a graduate work
at UNH in Marine Science specifically
seaweed and then I went on to teach at
Plymouth state to teach biology
I'm just thrilled to be on this
committee and
right
um Bob Healey this is my uh little loud
second term from Merrimack along with
rosemary rungh and Tim mcgu
um I've been retired I retired in 2010
and actually moved to the state in 2008
worked in the defense industry had a
large
contractor for 25 years in the software
field
and I've been on Lake Winnipesaukee
since 1986 camping so looking forward to
good morning everybody I'm Alexis
Simpson and I live in Exeter I represent
Exeter newfield's New Market in Stratham
and my first term I was on environment
and agriculture so I feel like this is a
really great place to be in resources
and there might be some overlapping of
the folks we work with and Des but it's
great to have the water the water side
of the work in front of us
um I have an undergraduate degree in
physics and so I ended up as a passion
getting into sustainable agriculture
policy in my life which really
intersects I think with a lot of the
work of resources in in some ways
but then also I have two teenage boys
who have always loved to be outside and
so we spend a lot of time outside
together
um let's see I guess in my other life
I'm an ordained minister in the United
Church of Christ and so that is my work
outside of the legislature
um
I think that's it for now thanks
thank you um last but not least
um I'm Juliette Harvey bolia I represent
Tilton and samberton
um and this is my second term uh here on
R D I'm also the clerk so
um all the tabulating your votes and
please feel free to correct me or uh
double check me at any time I love to
have people uh helping me out in that
way so I'm delighted to meet everyone
uh representative gold and rep then
the gold from Bedford New Hampshire and
my love is bicycle riding and taking
watching what's going on with the rail
trails in New Hampshire
uh this is my fifth term and uh
I was the high school Latin teacher for
a while and uh
that's it nice to meet everybody all you
yeah and I'm representative Eamon Kelly
uh representing the city of Berlin plus
the towns of Whitefield Jefferson and
Carroll
um I'm a second term here in the house
second term on resources uh before uh in
my other my other job is uh by working
for my family Sawmill so I grew up
around the forest uh forestry industry
um and I'm uh happy to bring that to
we are missing one vote one person uh
thanks
representative
I think oh by the way since I don't I'm
I'm just going to go by a seating chart
I don't want to turn your things toward
me I wish they wish they would I wish
ones that we have yeah because I like I
can
uh other representative involvement how
did you get one so fast
there must have been somebody oh wait
it's tough reading those little ones
especially when you're got old glasses
and
older older eyes yeah
uh by the way uh I think mostly I might
have might have figured out that these
uh
these we have all do we have live mics
here so uh if you've been visiting new
folks
yeah there's when you turn them off
you still uh they are being
these this this is being recorded uh
we're uh on uh on YouTube so uh you know
careful careful thoughts this way
careful what you say that uh that you
don't want to maybe get in the newspaper
or something like that but uh and I I'm
I'm as bad as everybody also uh when you
finish speaking uh try to shut it off
because when you uh you get too many too
many mics on and this the system they
they don't uh doesn't work as well so it
it takes all the juice to the from the
it just divides up the uh the power so
you've you know so it interferes with
the pure person speaking
uh a couple of additional things
uh
and I've been asked that
talk to folks about the financial
disclosure form
a lot of people you have yet to fill it
out
it is uh it is a
you can you can allow you gotta fined
for not to
handing it in it's it's a it is a state
statute state law but I don't know of
anybody who's ever been fined but I
don't want to be the first one so uh
so fill it out get it get it I guess the
date the end the the
trip date is uh is Friday
uh so try to get it in there is you can
put it in through the portal
I guess so uh
or you could get one and and fill it out
any
anything uh
representative harb representative Vale
on a uh
want to know how we if you want to know
how we're we we operate you'll you'll
you'll be seeing that shortly uh
you all have the new folks I presume
have all had the been to the orientation
so
yeah they're that's very I know that's
like you know drinking through a fire
hose so there's a lot of you know a lot
of information tossed at you but uh just
watching you know we'll do every there's
enough uh senior people in here both
parties will you know be glad to if they
see you they'll try to give you you see
you're going off the uh down the wrong
lane they'll they'll say they'll they'll
say they'll tell you something and uh or
they'll they'll whisper to you or I
would hope they'd whisper and uh you
know just to obey just to help you uh
you know get through the first couple of
a couple of hearings and uh
other than that uh if you as as we're
going through if you if there's
something you don't understand
especially in the beginning there's no
such thing as a stupid question you know
you don't have you need an answer
uh and you know we'll we'll we'll take
that into account and we'll we'll try to
answer your question or hopefully
uh so and if you notice the uh with the
seating arrangement I tried to do it uh
well I've got supposed to try to there's
a whole lot of things you would want to
you want to be able to to do but one
thing we did were able to do uh is
fairly fairly reasonably is uh alternate
uh r d
to be able to get uh you know people of
the different different parties next to
each other
so that we are we most of the work we do
turns out to be fairly bipartisan uh
yeah we there there may be a cup there
may be a few bills that we're going to
be 10 10 on that's the that's the nature
of the beast that's but uh you know we
we can be we can have a different
opinion
but I think we'll all eventually
eventually like each other I don't think
I've uh
actually the only person I never I'm not
going to go into that
no Rosemary don't look good
[Laughter]
that's right
it was somebody from a from my own party
many many years ago back
2011. so anyway
yes
thank you Mr chair um the days that
we're going to meet how many bills you
think we're going to have
um is this a good time to share that
how how much how many bills we have left
or what how many bills do we have now as
of that we know about we have 17 now so
we still have 17. yeah we still have 17
now they're uh there will I think
I thought there was 50 uh remaining and
there's still 50 remaining and we still
got extra bills so uh
but that's we it may be a possibility of
one uh maybe another one but I I you
know luck of the draw
but uh shouldn't be anything we can't
easily handle we did get one rather
large Bill a large meaning of going to
be a lot a lot of testimony a lot of I
think you're probably all seeing it now
with the uh the
amount of uh writing your amount of
emails you're getting and that's the one
on the Lake Winnipesaukee
uh speed limit
that's perennial bill seems to show up
uh every uh every year and uh
luckily it it was it has been with
transportation
for the last uh five terms or so
and
now they've decided to give it back to
us we had it originally
I was
years ago I was able to get get a change
to Transportation but
now they're back
it's back so we will probably have it
that hearing especially in the
uh in the rep in reps Hall
because I don't think this room will
take it at least that but I'm
any other uh any other thoughts
questions uh we will be having I haven't
we will eventually be having uh some
exact of some executive sessions uh to
be able to uh
handled the bills that uh that we're
getting uh
that we
uh those those are yet that's yet to be
uh
yet to be scheduled again we are I'm
trying and it seems to be working so far
to make Wednesday is our day I think we
gotta we don't have so many bills we're
not like Municipal and County and an e e
DNA which you've got a hundred bills
I know I know education has over a
hundred bills and
they are
flat out
but we're not we have with 17 bills
that's that's easy that's that's slower
than we had last year
okay
is what you get
so
uh
any other any other questions or any uh
as
like an answer
concerns
uh yeah
uh we will normally be is when we uh we
have a certain allotted time for the
bill for the for the bills
uh if Bill runs over
we just well we'll keep going and then
we'll pick up the the next one and then
that uh in the sequence of in the
calendar and uh if we finish early on a
bill we'll just take a break we cannot
start
ahead of the what's on the calendar
other than that uh
Oh by well by the way this afternoon we
are going to Des
uh we have they'll you'll be seeing a
lot of the people that you'll be project
that have that the predominance of the
bills that we actually take up uh are
with the with Des if you notice as for
the bills that we have today
are not Des I thought it would be rather
rather crude to have bills this in the
morning and then go see have them and go
visit them in the afternoon I think they
probably want to have a little bit of
time to prepare for
right for for their meet and greet so
yeah
uh we'll get there at 1 30. uh and uh
which should be over by three
yeah if someone needs you know the uh
it's
not locking anybody nobody's locked in
so but yeah it but it should be over by
three uh the speaker wants us to wait to
be
you use our use the use our time wisely
and he he he was like he
likes we would like to wanna you know
starting at nine and
uh ending you could end this light is
five I will not do that I mean I will
usually end up uh at the end at the end
well I will starting to start at nine
yes yes uh at the
for the the last bill of the day will
usually be the longest one and we'll
usually schedule that so that we're not
here till five
it's not my intention
I have I have made a mistake every now
and then but we have gone beyond that
but not not normally
uh
any other any other thoughts any other
questions if not
yeah you'd be back here at uh water up
right nine
forty five for
relative to the filing of notice of the
I have a pill that I need to introduce
Municipal at 12. so I don't not sure
when I can make it over there uh you'll
probably will be trying to be out of
problems
unless those questions about violence
yep
things
that's one of my that's my last
advantage
well I was too deep into engineering
yeah I was making a good money in
engineering and it would have to you
know
your son was introduced the other day
but I couldn't stand is he like four
how old he's uh 19. yes thank you I
think he knows
um so back to Timber
um yeah I'll get with uh bino and see if
he can switch his dates to like a
Thursday it looks like we're not going
to have sessions on the 26th yeah look
like they're not which is lucky yeah so
maybe we could squeeze them in there I
think people will come on the school
vacation week that's the school vacation
week that's why we don't have a session
women
no which which vacation in February
I don't have kids in school anymore I
mean everybody on that committee is it's
pretty old not you know I'm not going
away usually the people with kids that
go away yeah I think most of those
people are not uh young so
damn sure is aging you were gonna do one
of those things maybe you can you do
this thing can you do that question for
that day
can I take questions for that yeah you
were going to send some thing out or to
me to send out to people what's a good
day oh you know what um can we do a
survey monkey for one day before we just
schedule I don't think it will just
schedule it for Thursday I mean I only
have one and what day is that is it
actually March or is it February well we
can
I mean I'll check
that's the timber Amendment
um let me ask so we're we're booked up
for all the Wednesdays from here on out
right well for a while because I got to
schedule the next couple of meetings and
then we have the exact sessions so he's
got two worst case
two more days and then a day for a sofa
exec so we may be done in five days but
it depends how long all these things
take when they carry over
oh I see what you're saying yeah we
could just push it off until late in
February or March
we gotta have the
uh
mid-February we have to have to be
finished with our early books so as we
got
uh so you'll be done that next week yeah
yeah exactly hopefully there's no uh
nothing we don't have any work sessions
then I'll figure out no I don't have one
yet I think it's just better to
[Music]
yeah
time the problem the problem with the
Wednesday is if we go four or five more
weeks we won't have a Timber commission
meeting
for two three months
oh no because he's taking up all the
Wednesdays and we're gonna have
well there's probably going to be a
break
at crossover time I would assume
is
yeah you were thinking March anyway
right
I thought we'd have
here's what I was thinking the next
meeting we're just going to talk about
bills have
um
so anyway and I'll ask Andy if he's if
he doesn't have a meeting the week of a
vacation then we can do Wednesday then
okay yeah I just think
foreign
and I'm just thinking we got so many I
got so many issues to cover before
December
even if four of us show up get the issue
done and yeah I don't know but I'll talk
no just told me off the top of that he
would like to do this for us and he's
probably the best person out there but
there's some politics out there
some people want to get in on it talk to
the legislators so no he's trying to
work that out I didn't think we were
okay
all right we're going to get started
I'm open to hearing on
House Bill
174 relative to the filling uh the
filing excuse me of notice of intent to
cut timber
chair recognizes
Juliet Harvey bullya representative just
uh to introduce the bill
chair is yours okay thank you very much
Mr chair and members of the committee
um as I just introduced myself but I
should have added that I'm also on the
um low grade Timber and Emerging Markets
commission which is is in the same
subject matter as the bill I'm
introducing
um so let me just formally introduce
myself for the record I am
representative Juliet Harvey Boley
representing Tilton and samberton
um and I'm introducing house bill 174.
relative to the filing of notice of an
intent to cut timber
I'd like you to please refer to
Amendment
003h which I've given you all copies or
some of you already printed them out but
thank you
um we're I'm going to work off of this
amendment because it's uh it removes
some basic housekeeping things from the
original bill which is uh remove some
repeated text it fixed the numbering and
lettering system and it adds clarific
clarification but it didn't change the
context of the bill so if you could
please uh work off of that
Amendment I'd appreciate it
um but basically I filed this bill on
behalf of the New Hampshire Timber
Owners Association and it fixes a
problem for the Foresters while still
providing everything town the town needs
and has come to expect from this process
which works off of the intent to cut
timber form
woodcutters and Foresters have short
windows of time to cut timber
their Harvest is dependent on particular
weather conditions which you'll hear
more about from the actual Foresters
uh and if they don't get a response from
towns regarding the paperwork the intent
to cut timber in a timely manner which
we'll go into millions of dollars of
lumber equipment may lie idle leaving
them unable to plan or cut in some cases
and not knowing if or when they will get
a response from the town that was
supposed to issue their permit within 15
days which is the law and it is noted on
the permit
um so that is the problem the bill seeks
to address is uh the notice of intent to
cut forms are not being sent to dra
which is the Department of Revenue
Administration
um not I'm not saying this happens in
every case but it happens probably in at
least six cases last year with six towns
um
so it puts the timber operations at a
standstill which results in a loss of
Revenue
which um you'll hear more about how
important the timber industry is to one
of the most forested states in the Union
uh before a Timber Harvest can begin a
tax document must be filed with a town
and the town is legally obligated to
respond which is sign it and notify the
landowner of deficiencies so there are
four deficiencies and they are located
on the timber tax form itself and
they're very simple
um which is just all owners of record
have signed so they must check that
um they can they can look up in the tax
cards who's you know one of the owners
how many owners there are
um number two the land is not under
current use unproductive category the
form is complete and accurate
uh which is a little bit vague
um and any timber tax Bond required has
been received so those are the four
criteria on the permit itself the law
does not say what happens after 15 days
if the landowner or logger doesn't hear
back from the town
the issue occurs in a variety of towns
across the state not just in one area
so to get into the actual Amendment here
I'd like if you could refer to sub
paragraph C
so this bill provides an answer and
guidance to what happens after the 15
days say the logger you know files they
haven't heard back
um they contact era to see what's going
on with the process
and that's it they don't hear anything
more
um so in that case we have uh
change the change it to a I won't call
it an automatic issue but for lack of a
better term I'll say it's a
semi-automatic issue of permit
so we'll allow them to start logging if
they haven't heard back but then give
the towns an option for tracking them
down and ceasing the operations if they
need to so
they haven't heard back line 30.
um if the conditions for approval have
not been met the owner may come commence
the The Cutting operation in accordance
with the intent
but if the assessing officials
thereafter determine that the conditions
of for approval have not been met
the assessing officials shall notify the
owner and the person responsible for the
cutting explaining why the submitted
intent does not meet the conditions for
signature
upon delivery of the notice saying
please stop the cutting operation shall
cease until such conditions are met in
the intent to the signed so
changing it to Ace like what I'll call a
semiotic semi-automatic issue of permit
removes the burden in case in the case
that a assessing official for the towns
just forgotten you know say they put it
aside and or they're new and they they
seriously just aren't sure how the
permit process works and they don't want
to approve it but at any rate
if it doesn't get formed
the logger can now start
with the option of the the town can then
find them if for some reason
they want to fix one of those four
deficiencies so this bill does not
impact what it doesn't do is impact
other state and local approvals such as
the surface water quality protection act
the basal area law that leaves forested
buffers or it doesn't impact alteration
of terrain permits all other
environmental concerns that are
addressed in rsas elsewhere and the
statute are not affected by this it
doesn't diminish Town authority to
approve and not approve it and attend to
cut
taxes will still get collected as they
need to
um and there's one other issue one other
item on here but I'm going to have
um the speakers that are coming after me
address
the addition of the five business days
which is on line 24. it was something
that dra
the Department of Revenue Administration
was consulted and asked for their input
and they suggested this five business
day clarification
instead of the assessing officials shout
immediately forward
it's more reasonable to say five
business days which I agree so I thank
you very much and I will be happy to
do any questions by members of the
committee
representative wrong
thank you Mr chairman
um
representative on line 28 of the
amendment it talks about the uh intent
is not signed by the assessing officials
within 15 days is that 15 calendar days
or business days because I noticed in
line 24 it it's fifth with within five
business days
uh thank you
representative from
um so
the 15 days in line 28 refers back to
the 15 uh I'm sorry line number 14 which
is
um in the original language
and I am not sure if that is calendar
calendar days I guess yeah okay thank
you
you're welcome any other questions from
members of the committee
representative wolf for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um I see this as a potential problem
with assessing officials and getting it
to the selectment or the governing
entity in town that it can be held up
especially if you have outside assessors
in the town and I think that's where we
may have some issues in some of these
towns that haven't
delivered these things in a
proper time proper time
um I I think there needs to be some work
between assessing officials and the
reporting officials and uh I believe
it's the select one have to ultimately
sign off on it and I don't see any
reference to that in here so I'm just
concerned that I think the intent of the
bill is great but I think it needs some
representative harp for a question
thank you for taking my question
um I'm also focusing on the 15 days I
haven't had a chance to read the entire
RSA 79 do you happen to know if the 15
if the notice has to be sent by
certified or registered mail because I
wonder when do they start the 15 day
um thank you
um
I don't I mean the 15 days is so they
yeah so dra has to get back the town has
to get back to them
there isn't anything in here about
sending it certified but as I understand
it and I'm sure uh Mr stock will clarify
a lot of this too but um
there's a lot of Correspondence that
goes on by email such as like you're you
know what I understand you're cleared to
go your permit's been signed you may
start now
um I'm sure some towns I know because I
have worked for a town and I before this
I worked I was on the planning board for
like six years
so I'm all Vaguely Familiar with some of
this um some towns will will um
will send things certified mail when
they are not required to so it's it's I
think it's up to the um is up to the
town really there's no sometimes send
everything's you know we're more likely
to send things certified mail than than
other towns which may know and be
familiar with the logger and just uh
communicate casually with them is that
does that answer your question
maybe he was big and this is honest
sorry to interrupt maybe some of these
questions
um on the more nitty-gritty would be
better answered by uh Mr stock who would
uh who's intimately involved in this as
opposed to you know yourself who's you
know but maybe he uh would be would you
be satisfied with the discussion with Mr
stock I'd be happy for Mr stock dance
and my question uh if it's like a
statute of limitations uh as my other
life as you know I'm a lawyer I'd like
to know that the logger knows once they
get that notice on a certain date he can
start counting the 15 days some statutes
say you know three days from certified
delivery or whatever so maybe Mr stock
can answer that question thank you any
other questions uh there's any of Darby
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question on in in the
amendment or in the um yeah I mean uh on
Section D it says that
um the notice will be sent to the tax
collector 30 days after signing but if
the you know the town hasn't signed it
then
um you know it seems like there's a
disconnect The cutting's Happening
um you know 15 days after it's submitted
but they decide for some reason not to
sign it and how does the how would then
yeah I'm I'm uh would you be satisfied
representative Darby if if I'll allow
um Mr stock here to
finish answering some of these questions
about sure thank you and then he can
all right any other questions from
members of the uh of the committee
seeing none of course I'm feeling good
to get a Nick I have to get a neck brace
to keep bending over to see people in
the end uh
thank you very much representative if
oh yeah I will
uh Mr Alex chair recognizes Mr stock
I got my
talked to the
I presume you have some stuff to stand
out
you really you you
I know you figure might as well use up
foreign
absolutely thank you and uh for the
record my name is Jason stock I'm the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Timberland Owners Association
and I I appreciate and thank you for the
opportunity to come and speak to you
this morning
um in setting this up
because this is the first time they've
been in front of a lot of you I figured
it would be a good opportunity to kind
of introduce Who We Are
but also introduce you to the the
state's Timberland owner Timberland as
well as the state's Forest products
industry
so you have some information there's
kind of two parts to your package one is
some general information the other is
some information that's quite specific
to the the piece of legislation we're
discussing
um
a little bit about us nhtoa we were
founded in 1911 we have about 1200 1300
members
and we represent Timberland owners and
of course we we also represent as I like
to say the entire food chain loggers
Foresters Sawmills biomass or wood chip
power plants
um and yes paper mills so we are not we
are not bashful about using paper
we support our members by using paper as
well
um
we do three things we do advocacy work
but we also do education we have a
pretty extensive education industry
educational program for for folks in the
industry logging professionals as well
as Sawmills and wood processors
everything from safety to best
management practices for erosion control
and water quality
um and safe chainsaw operation we do a
lot of this work in cooperation with the
UNH University of New Hampshire Thompson
School of applied science but also UNH
Cooperative Extension so we work very
closely and we run a a certification
program for logging professionals and so
um so that's part of kind of who we are
what we do the the third thing we do is
we do Communications and Outreach a
reporter wants to know what do
landowners think we've got this new bug
on this scene called emerald ash borer
what do landowners think about that many
times where the the organization I don't
get the call and say all right
you know this is what the state's Ash
resource looks like this is our concern
Etc
so that's a little bit about who we are
and and I included my business card you
have a copy of our magazine that's our
latest magazine that we we just
published give you a little flavor of
what we do who we are and if you ever
have any questions feel free to call me
Timberland in the state of New Hampshire
New Hampshire is the second most
forested state in the nation we're about
83 percent forested
um
I talk to folks unfamiliar with the
state you say who's the most forested
State what are the top three they said
well Alaska Washington Oregon and that's
not true as a percent of land base New
Hampshire is the second behind Maine
um we have our Our Land base is about I
believe the number is 72 percent is
private privately owned
um very different than out west where
it's almost the opposite a lot of a lot
of federally owned land out west here in
the in the Northeast
um much of the land three quarters of it
is privately owned uh
the these and
let me see here
seven and ten percent is state and local
and the FED Zone about 18 White Mountain
National Forest some Wildlife refuges so
the state of New Hampshire the the
federal government does own a pretty
good piece of New Hampshire real estate
but on the whole private land it's about
75 percent
um landowners in New Hampshire come in
all shapes and sizes we have landowners
that own 10 acres to a real estate
investment trust Timber investment
organizations that will own literally
hundreds of thousands of Acres
principally up north in the northern
part of the state if you look at the
state and break it into thirds if you
think of the state as kind of
the northern tip down to the White
Mountains a lot of the Timber up there
is it's more of a boreal forest
Spruce fur
those types of species you get into the
the White Mountains down through the
down into the Lakes Region you have
what's called a northern northern
hardwood forest
a lot of sugar maple Yellow Birch you do
get some ash in there as well and then
if you think of the bottom third of the
state
it's more of a pine pine Oak Forest and
then if you get right down on the coast
or on the bottom very bottom of the
state you start getting some real
interesting species in in that area
you'll get a little bit of cherry you
get sometimes Hickory and some other
White Oaks that start to mix in so we
have a very diverse Forest
our forest right now and I provided you
a copy this is of this neat document
from this U.S department of Agriculture
this is they do a they have a survey a
forest survey program called fia the
forest inventory analysis
and throughout the state there are
hundreds and hundreds of secret
test plots and they go out and across
these plots across the state they do
analysis on what's growing what's
removed they test everything not only
the types of trees the growth how much
biomass is there right on down the line
and this is a program that's been in
place for many decades and so you're
able to start developing some Trends but
if you look at the bars on the right
hand side of this
you'll see that our annual growth
is around 310 million cubic feet
mortality is 106 removals logging is
112. our net is 92 meaning we continue
to grow more wood in the state of New
Hampshire than we Harvest and that is
dying of natural mortality
our forests are getting older
um and just like us as you get older you
grow slower
and so we're watching this you know as
an as as landowners and as an industry
we watch this growth curve pretty
closely but we're happy to say that we
continue to grow more wood than we
Harvest and we have a very healthy and a
very resilient Forest unlike you see out
west where you'll have uh wildfires and
some of the crazy natural natural
catastrophes hit our forests tend to be
quite resilient in that and part of it
is the diversity of tree species our
humid environment
Etc
shift gears talk about the industry you
also have in your packet
a document called Forest Products
Industries economic contribution
that's this document
um
this is just the executive summary
there are web links to this and if
someone wants to watch a printed copy
I'm more than happy to print it for you
but this this was an economic analysis
that looked at the forest products
industry and a few takeaways so direct
direct economic output looking at
and this is from stump to finished
product it's about 1.6 billion dollars a
year of economic output that comes from
the state's Forest products industry
if you look at direct indirect and
what's called induced so this is the
logger logger in The Sawmill are direct
there are people working with the boards
working with the saws indirect are the
companies that support them the Napa
Auto Parts that sell millions of dollars
of hydraulic equipment to the loggers
HMC a sawmill manufacturer that sells
lot saw milling equipment to this to The
Sawmill if you include those indirect
and then the induced that's the sandwich
shop down this down the road that the
logger stops or the car dealership that
the mill owner visits that starts
approaching 2.5 billion
and so that's the kind of the the
economic
input if you look in the past I haven't
seen any recent numbers but within the
last 10 years if you look at Industries
Forest Products is one of the top three
um manufacturing sectors of the state
um it's it's when you look at
all the industries as a whole Forest
Products is is one of the top three
um and people are surprised to hear that
we don't have big factories along the
river in Manchester right next to the
interstate all our work happens out in
the woods and in small rural communities
sprinkled throughout the state
we have about two dozen commercial
sawmills
um these are and there are many many
smaller Mills portable Mills things of
that nature across the state but we have
just over two dozen larger commercial
Sawmills that saw all species all
products
um in terms of Timber harvesting if you
look at the state's Timber tax data one
of the things we glean from this the
timber attacks and and report of cuts
and intent to Cuts is we get a very good
data set
about about two two and a half million
tons of wood is harvested every year
that's all products all species so
that's red maple going into firewood
that's eastern white pine going to a
sawmill to make uh to make Lumber it's
all products all species
um we have in terms of logging
contractors this number has we have seen
some
uh some I'll say uh erosion on this
number over the past couple years due to
some Market some shifts in markets and
loss of some low-grade markets hence the
the commission that
representative harb is is is leading up
but logging we estimate there's about
anywhere from This Is Us
I'll say a squishy number and it's
because we have about I'll say 900 to a
thousand you know I say it's squishy
because I may own a skitter I may cut
wood in the winter and then in the
summer I say all right I'm going to do
some fishing and I have an excavator and
I may do some some earth work so am I a
logger am I but we estimate that there's
about eight anywhere from nine hundred
to a thousand logging contractors across
the state
um licensed Foresters these are folks
that are professional Foresters they're
licensed with the state's licensing uh
The Joint licensing board they're about
two just over 250 licensed Foresters
across the state and they provide they
provide landowners consultation guidance
some of them actually work for Mills in
the purchase wood for Mills
so and then in terms of biomass power
plants we have
we have several that are idle we have
two that two that are currently two that
are currently operating a large power
plant up in Berlin that's burning wood
chips to make electricity up in Berlin
and then a second one in Ashland if you
head north on 93 and you go past the
Ashland exit if you look to the left
you'll see a stack that's Bridgewater
power some of you visited Bridgewater
power this past summer to get a feel for
it again important part of the industry
because it's a market for low-grade wood
about two-thirds of everything we grow
in this state is considered low grade
it's an it's a function of the trees
it's the nature of our trees it's the
species it's how they grow and so
markets for that are important if you're
going to practice sustainable forestry
it's like weeding a garden you need to
have a place to take these weeds biomass
is one paper mills had historically been
a very important Market that industry is
certainly contracted although I'll say
there are Mills in Western Maine that we
that a lot of New Hampshire wood goes to
and one over in Glens Falls New York
so that's that's the
kind of the big picture the industry
um in your packet and to kind of get
into the bill itself house bill 174. I
it's called
reported volume by County April 1 2020
to March 31 2021. this is a document
from the New Hampshire Department of
Revenue
and
representative bullio Harvey bolio got
into this when you file an intent to cut
the town receives it
hopefully they review it within 15 days
this bill is going to address the
question of what happens after 15 days
if they don't sign it or let you know
there's an issue so
they
that intent to cut gets signed
that tells the town okay there's a
Timber sale that's going to occur on
this piece of property
and you can anticipate tax revenue it is
a notice of intent to cut
some people call them permits some
people call them approvals it is a
notice putting the town on notice that
hey and it's a it's pure tax document
this is what's going to happen on this
property you can anticipate taxes
Town gets that document in in this
particular tax year there were 2
327 Timber sales across the state of New
Hampshire
there's almost every town Sees at least
one timber sale in the state of New
Hampshire every year and I'll say almost
you get on the sea coasts there's not a
lot of wood to be cut in some of those
communities but Statewide almost every
town sees a at least one timber sale
so so that intent to cut gets filed I
provided you a copy of this document
this is the intent intent to cut
you'll see it is an estimate you you
provide
the landowner logger or Forester tells
the town all right
here's the tax Lot number
here's the
you see that information on the left
column
this is this is kind of identifies where
it's going to occur
um the type of ownership
and then on the right column you'll see
the table and they provide an estimate
these are how an mbf is an abbreviation
for board feet
um thousand board feet this is an
estimate so you say all right we walked
the property we think we're going to
harvest 50 000 board feet of eastern
white pine 20 000 board feet of uh
of spruce fur or Yellow Birch and one
thousand board feet of Oak
the the person responsible for the cut
that could be the logger that could be
the Forester and the landowner signed
this
um sometimes there may be joint
ownership
um a husband and wife jointly owned the
parcel they would both sign it
um and the the law has Provisions in
this that it okay there's a partnership
you get the partners to sign it they
send it into the town the town receives
this they have 15 days
and
the second document from dra that I
provided is a synopsis of New Hampshire
Timber tax law
and you'll see the four points on the
front of this
that representative Harvey bolia
had mentioned
front page on the bottom
did they complete the form properly
is it an unproductive category
what is unproductive what is
unproductive land think of a large bog
our Marsh area an area that just won't
produce Wood high elevation where
there's just your above tree line
um you know is the land has the
landowner
is it unproductive obviously if it's
unproductive why would you be harvesting
Timber if it's not there so this is a
check to make sure okay yeah this is
this is legitimate
um is a bond required bonds are
typically required for typically for two
reasons if I if I'm back if I'm if I owe
the town taxes already
say I'm behind on my taxes I tell the
town okay I'm going to cut my wood maybe
I'm going to cut my wood to pay the town
the town says that's great Jason but we
want to make sure that if you skip town
that there's some surety that we will
get that tax revenue they will require a
bond the second place where bonds get
required is and you'll hear about this
from one of the future speakers here the
second place is if it's state state or
federal land
um bear Brooks State Park White Mountain
National Forest when they do a Timber
harvest the logger will complete this
this governmental entity owns the land
but the logger will complete an intent
to cut
they'll complete an intent to cut for
the sale they submitted to the town and
they do the they do the timber sale on
the state park the reservation State
Reservation or the federal land and then
they and they build into their bid
Timber taxes and they will pay the town
a Timber tax so the town still gets
Revenue even though it's publicly owned
land
um
so that's that's another piece but in
that instance
the towns well very Mo will typically
say look
ER you know Chopper Bob you don't own
that land that's owned by the state of
New Hampshire or that's owned by the U.S
department of Agriculture we would like
to see a bond
so that
um if there's some mix-up we want to be
assured that we will get our our taxes
um so so those are two instances where
taxes tax bonds would be required the
other two items on the list for for
withholding a signature is owners of
record
husband and wife a uh you know a joint
ownership such as a husband and wife
um Partnerships if they both don't sign
it again that can that can be a hold up
so yeah so those are the four those are
the four four reasons
um
the town and it's right now in law it is
illegal for that logger to start
harvesting without an intent to cut
you just can't you can't start legally
you will get a violation there are
forest rangers there's a Timber tax
assessor
um that will come they'll shut you down
you'll get fined it's not a pretty
picture so it's really important this
document is kind of a a gatekeeper to to
when you can start that project move
your equipment on and start it so having
this document
signed and approved is really you know
getting that approval is is really
important if you're going to try to get
things get things rolling
in towns by law have 15 days
and they are calendar days
they have 15 days to say yes we sign off
on it or
you missed it one of your owners of
record or we want a bond they have 15
days to get back to you one of the
problems we have is that there are towns
and and I don't I I don't want to say
it's always malicious
but there are towns that will just not
get back to you you submit it it goes to
the town clerk the town clerk signs date
stamps it says okay I received this on
on January 18th boom thank you and in
many instances I would say two-thirds of
the time the the town Clinton
review the tax cards okay owners of
record have signed all the owners of
record it's filled out correctly there
aren't any back taxes and they'll hand
it off in in most like I said two-thirds
of the time off to the selectman it goes
on the agenda and the selectman will
review it and sign it at the next
selectman's meeting if and so the
question has come up what if the
Selectmen don't meet within 15 days
that was contempt that is already
contemplated in the law the law says all
right if for some reason those Selectmen
don't meet
sorry don't meet in 15 days
they can they can put a a 24-hour notice
they post a 24-hour notice that an
intent to cut was received and
then after 24 hours notice the Selectmen
can sign it in many instances what will
happen is it'll go on a stack of papers
usually invoices and receipts and as the
Selectmen cycle through the town office
over the next 13 days they'll they'll
sign it and your everyone's set ready to
go
um
the
there are instances where we have seen
across the state an intent to cut
will get submitted well
we're gonna we're gonna sit on this we
want we think you need to we need we
think you'll need a driveway permit we
think there are wetlands out there
um we mean the town we would like the
Conservation Commission to review your
intent to cut
um
and in those instances I come back to
this is a tax document it those issues
there are other agencies that deal with
that there are other Regulators that are
watching that so and and it is
that is not a a there are only four
reasons
that a an intent to cut can be held up
from signature and so whether you
anticipate we want to Road Bond we need
a driveway permit we think you should
file a Wetlands permit that's irrelevant
for this particular document there are
other laws in place there are Rangers
they're Des folks out there that
regulate that this is a separate
separate entity altogether
why 15 days why is this important
and you'll hear from a an individual
who's in the logging business
when you're operating a logging business
you'll have a couple million dollars
worth of capital this isn't just guys
with pickup trucks and a chainsaw
anymore these are mechanized operations
you'll have a couple million dollars in
capital you have payroll and so lining
up work
future work
um becomes really important you want to
keep your Capital want to keep your
Capital operating at the same time you
want to keep your Crews busy
um and you line projects up with an
expectation that okay in 15 days
I'm going to be able to move on to the
I'll I should have I should have the
approvals my paperwork was in order I
should be able to move on to this lot in
15 days if that gets hung up
if for some reason
I don't hear back
now what do I do it's illegal for me to
begin and so I'm stuck I can't move my
crew my equipment is idle and there's a
there's a financial and operational
burden there
um
weather a day like today you get a nice
nice warm spell it seems like we get a
lot of them these days in January and
February I may be on a logging job I
have a couple days of rain I have a
second job kind of my backup my plan B
I've got the intent to cut filed
15 days comes and goes we get a couple
days on my primary job I say look we got
to pull out we don't want to make a mess
we don't want to make ruts we want to
pull out and move to this higher drier
ground
if I don't have that approval again I'm
stuck so whether also becomes a becomes
an issue
when we crafted this bill
we looked at it and we said all right
um we don't
we didn't in in the attorney that I
worked with said well Jason why don't
you just say after 15 days it's
automatically approved there are other
regulatory permit programs that do that
you could just say you know there you
provide your notice and you're just good
to go if you don't hear back in 15 days
and although as appealing as that was I
said look you know this is a tax
document this is dealing with tax
records
let's let's provide a safety let's
provide a safety catch here or a check
where I can start on day 16. after I
filed that intent to cut and it's been
date stamped I file it I start my
operation if at that point the town says
well wait a minute
um there's a typo on your on your
document or you know the husband and
wife they both didn't sign it you need
to get that second signature
in this in this bill we said all right
they notify me and this is to
representative harb's question they
provide a notification right now it's
it it's it's very uh it's not certified
or registered mail and we tried to
address that in the bills that they
provide a notice the we originally had a
letter in there providing a letter but
again recall time is of the essence and
in I would say 99.999 of the time it's a
phone call
hey hey looked at your intent to cut it
looks like you got a typo here your Lot
number your Lot number doesn't match up
can we can we fix this let's let's Rec
let's Rectify this and so what we did
was in the bill we said they provide you
a note they notify you
you cease operations
you work it out they and then if to
their satisfaction they sign it you're
you're back you're you're able to run
again so we didn't want to just say uh
assume they're all assume they're all
all approved we wanted to try to take a
measured approach and not just kind of
ram rot it through
we didn't want to be punitive
we didn't want to come in and say well
if you don't sign this in 15 days we're
going to tag you the town a thousand
dollars a day for every day that this
isn't signed starting on day 16. we said
we didn't want to approach that we work
with the towns we wanted to be we wanted
to be accommodating but also recognizing
that we have timetables and that we want
to be able to to operate and move
forward and so we didn't want to be
punitive and kind of create an
and we didn't want to throw extra
burdens on a town we didn't want to
create another bureaucratic process
um or add additional burden to towns
we're basically saying look day 16 let
us start
and at that point if you do come back
and you see an issue with it notify us
and then at that point
we'll take a time out let's fix it and
then let's move forward
in the bill there is the five-day
provision I wanted to talk about that
um and that is on looking at the
amendment
page one
lines 23 24.
so
doing my due diligence and preparing
this
um and in vetting it with some of the
stakeholders dra was amongst them they
did not
they didn't the only comments that they
provided was
we dra will hear regularly from towns
what does immediately mean it says you
immediately so I signed that I send my
intent to cut it gets signed
copy comes back to me and says Jason
you're good to go
the town is obligated now to send a copy
to the Department of Revenue
Administration current law says
immediately well he said well what does
that mean the selectman meet Tuesday
night does it have to be first thing
Wednesday morning
so to try to create to try to create
some kind of sideboards or guidance dra
had suggested five business days
I wanted to speak up speak to this
because someone would could ask Jason
why does the land why do the landowners
why are you concerned about this
interaction between the depart the town
and the department we put this in
um they had suggested that
they thought that was an improvement we
said fine we'll we'll put it in the bill
um and and move forward with it it does
provide some sideboards
um what is immediately that could mean a
the other piece is that we tried to
create a bill that didn't
um erode a Town's Authority
um to the extent that
they'd still have towns still have the
ability to say time out
Park your equipment we got to work this
out
we didn't want to erode a Town's
Authority but we also wanted to
recognize that towns have a legal
obligation they have 15 days to sign or
get back to me
so we want to recognize that they have a
legal obligation to fulfill but on the
other hand we didn't want to erode that
Authority so in crafting this bill
um we wanted to try to recognize those
two key points as well
um
if this does it sounds like there may be
some ideas about some other parts of it
and there may be a suggestion of a
subcommittee of some type if there is we
would be happy to participate in in that
in that discussion with that I'll
conclude my testimony I thank you for
bearing with me in in my forestry Timber
harvesting 101 Forest industry but thank
you again for the opportunity to speak
and and thank you for your attention
this this morning
I'd be happy to try and answer any
questions
thank you any questions from Members
remember the representative Lamontagne
thank you for taking my question
um it was mentioned a few times that
this has
um nothing to do with some issues like
conservation or Wetland but um I come
from the construction background and I
kind of look at this as the building
permit
but you don't get the building permit
until you've made sure that
other concerns that going through
planning or Conservation Commission have
been met and I'm wondering why there
isn't a sign off on this that that's
done in advance to make sure those
issues aren't
um
that if they need to be addressed
they're not already addressed
so good good question so this unlike a
building permit where you need to ensure
that you have your other ducks in a row
and your other approvals in place this
is this is quite simply a notice of
intent it's not it is not a a permit in
the sense that
it's it's not tied to other other
activities or other approvals that may
be out there
um it is purely a tax document we would
not support tying this to Wetlands
permits you know having this having
approval of this
um linked to Wetlands permits or
um
I can't think of uh you know Road
bonding or driveway permits it's just
we would not we could not support that
it is we like it as purely a tax
document we're providing a notice you
town can anticipate taxes
I don't know if I answered your question
it's not a but I I guess the the the
trick is try if you can try not to think
of it as a permit but as a notification
I'm trying to think of similarities in
the construction world and I I can't I
can't come up with any parallels but
for another question
yeah I just wanted a follow-up question
but it does seem to me that this is the
last thing that has to be signed before
the work can begin
so
not exactly and what I mean by that is
if if I have a project if I'm going to
cut timber
say I'm on a very high and dry site
there are no Wetlands on the site
then this this is I submit this
and I do my Timber Harvest 15 days comes
and goes I do my Timber Harvest if there
are wetlands Crossings on that site
and I have to obtain a Wetlands permit
and this can this this is not uncommon I
may have a hundred acres the first 50
acres are high and dry the back 50 there
are some Wetlands Crossings maybe
there's a brook that runs through there
and we need to cross it
in that instance I can file my intent to
cut I can harvest my start working give
and then the landowner says you know
what while you're here let's let's let's
do that forestry silvicultural treatment
on the back 50. all right we need to
First file a Wetlands permit with the
Department of Environmental Services and
of course they had
at that point then a notice goes to the
forest rangers and they know all right
there's a Wetlands Crossing when I go
out and inspect that job
one of the things I'm going to look for
is that but this is the web the types of
permits that a forestry job would obtain
differ site by site to sit so to tie
this to all all approvals may not be
appropriate because I may have a job
where
I don't need a Wetlands permit nor a
driveway permit or I may get into it
and the landowner decides something down
the road now I need it but I'm because
any other questions by members of the
committee
representative rung then representative
Derby
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
the way I'm understanding this bill the
amendment is so that the process moves
along and loggers aren't
prevented from moving forward on their
project because of inaction on the part
of the town is that is that a true
statement correct but when I was looking
through this document that you handed
out from the New Hampshire Department of
Revenue Administration
in the bottom part
um
there was something oh it's uh
in the last page
uh I mean the last paragraph of the
first page it says if the municipal
officials have not acted on the notice
to intend to cut within 15 days of
receipt the landowner should contact dra
who will inquire with the town as the
status and then the town has 15 days
so doesn't that resolve the issue of the
Town not responding to the notice of
intent to cut
um many times it will but we have had
instances where they say
thank you for your input we still want
to look at this or we still want to do
whatever before we sign that not that's
not common but we have had a couple
instances where that's that has occurred
so
thank you so
so what you're saying is that the the
logger could notify dra say we haven't
gotten a response yet from the town now
the town has 15 days to respond and
you're saying they don't do that or in
their response they just say we're still
holding on to it but did they just not
respond to the dra
I think
I don't know I don't know about their
Communications with dra what we have
seen is I file an intent to cut 15 days
comes and goes I call dra up and say hey
Town X I haven't heard back from them
um can you give them a call dra will
call them and almost you know most of
the time they will the town will say all
right yeah you know dra will it's kind
of the the heavy hand of of state
government but there have been instances
where towns have just said we're busy
we'll get to it when we get to it
it doesn't start the 15-day clock over
they still have 15 days from when that
gets date stamped when that town clerk
gets that document and date stamps it by
law they still have 15 days to act on it
calling dra on day 15 does not start a
second 15-day clock
representative Darby for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question I have two very short
questions hopefully
um the first is you you mentioned a
couple of the
um reasons why that the tax Bond might
be recorded but I was under the
impression reading RSA 793 AI there was
another case which is when the property
owner the signer does is not actually a
property owner in the town meaning that
they are you know maybe they live out of
state and they just retained and that's
actually one of the check marks on the
form you know they retained property
rights so is there a case where you know
the town might have to do some research
on the deed
um to in order to be able to determine
if a bond is required
great great question generally not
generally it's a pretty quick check they
can look at the tax card and say all
right here are the owners of record they
don't need to go in and do deed research
on it there'll be the tax card will be
pretty pretty cut and dry here here's
who owns that parcel
and here's who they send him a tax bill
annually so they usually have pretty
current information just to make sure I
understand you're saying that the tax
card would include who owns the timber
rights
terms of Timber rights if you purchase
if you separate the timber rights that
may be doesn't happen a lot but it can
happen I don't I don't know how that if
that does if that is reflected on the
the tax card or not I don't know on a
Timber rights issue again I'm not real
that doesn't happen a lot that's fine I
understand things my other question is
and this is
um following up on uh represent
representative montane's question for
the second question oh I'm sorry yep
go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um is
um
I understand that this is a tax uh this
is a tax document I get that and I
unders um but this tax document seems to
be the um momentum that generates the
environmental reviews by
um Des
um and there's a couple of cases I guess
and so as I as I read through you know
the the amendment and the original or I
say
um the the tax bill goes to the tax
administration they have to forward it
so that and that actually gives DS the
right to actually go on the property and
make and ensure that it is being
um that for example the Wetland laws are
being
um uh applied so again I'm my concern
here and I'm hoping you can comment on
this is that
um the you know if it's not signed if
because it's then it's the signing that
basically initiates this process
The Cutting may be virtually done before
or completely done before the
um before the tax Authority gets it and
they afford it over Des
I
to say that the cutting would be done I
mean they've had 15 day they've had this
document for 15 days that the town has
before I can even begin to move on it so
no cutting has occurred in that period
so the
you would hope that they would not sit
on it
much beyond that but
um so I don't know I don't think there's
the risk that you're going to have
situations where
they finally get her in my hope can
can't say anything's for certain but I
can't see a scenario where you would
have a situation where the cut totally
happens before the town gets around
designing this they should have already
reviewed it and signed it in the initial
15 days when nothing is happening if a
town is that
there may be something else going on
there the town is that far behind in
processing these things
thank you uh
where I go before we go on uh chair as
seen as feels that we may probably
leaning toward a work uh a work session
on this bill a
that that's be aware be aware of that
we'll I'll we'll talk about that uh at a
later date
any other questions
representative McHugh
thanks Mr chairman
thank you Mr stock for taking the
question and for bringing the bill to
help expedite some of these small
businesses in New Hampshire getting
their work done um
quick question I know we're a little
over time
um what's the replantation or
reforestation requirement either
federally or in New Hampshire on on
private or private land it's a great
question we we do not require replanting
and if you talk to a Forester
we have a problem controlling growth
unlike western western Forest where
replanting is a regular part of
operations
here
many of the hardwoods you cut a tree
they will stump Sprout and if there's a
deer hunter in the group they will know
find areas that had find a three
four-year-old clear-cut or patch cut and
you'll see a lot of stump Sprouts so one
of the challenges we have is managing
growth and replanting unless it's like a
Christmas tree farm or something like
that we have the we're very very
fortunate to not have to replant
yeah
thank you for that
education any other questions from
members of the committee
if seeing none thank you very much we've
thank you Mr chair nature Grace for the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
um just briefly we are a voluntary
membership organization that currently
comprises all 234 cities and towns
we provide legal advice to cities in
town so if you are a local official
you've probably caught our Legal Hotline
or familiar with it we do training
education for municipalities we did
about 80 events last year
um among the four people who do training
um and we also come here and advocate
um we are opposed to this legislation
and I recognize I'm probably the odd man
out here certainly if the inclination of
the committee is to have a subcommittee
we'd be happy to participate
um I believe that uh representative
LaMontagne kind of Hit Upon Our our main
objection
um here which is that we do Advocate to
maintain
um local control
um and we recognize certainly that if
there is an intent to cut filed a 15-day
period lapses and it's not signed off on
the logger doesn't get any communication
from
the municipality that is problematic for
everyone and we would like to work
towards finding a solution on that
um as representative rung noted um in
the in the dra
um or one of the documents that was
provided by Mr stock
um
generally the process right now is if
they don't hear back from municipality
you would call dra dra would out have
some sort of Outreach with
um the municipality and attempt to
resolve the issue
um that seems to be a appropriate
approach
um simply because dra is the one who
regulates taxation they're the ones who
would who would seem to be the
appropriate regulator
um we wouldn't want to be in a situation
where
um
loggers are cutting without any input
from the municipality because
we would have those concerns
um and I think Mr stock did a great
explanation about the whole process and
the different slides but some of our
members are concerned about about those
those other agencies and groups and
their input into the process and making
sure all the appropriate regulatory
authorities are notified
um when when they
become aware of situations because of
course select ports are in charge of
making sure their whole town runs so
they're not just in charge of
a very narrow area whether taxation or
anything else but they also
really do have to try to coordinate all
the various local boards and help
everyone Row in the same direction
so that's the input that we heard from
our members when we reached out to them
on this and I'll keep my testimony to
that
I'm not happy to answer any questions
any questions
Mr
Q
thank you Mr chairman
can you tell us how often they can't get
it done in 15 days and why
so my understanding is it really breaks
down to two different areas one is you
have someone new on staff who's the
admin person or whatever comes in the
logger comes in
hands in the form and they don't
understand they're supposed to do
something within 15 days and that is
usually quickly corrected the other one
is
um
there are some
municipalities who do a little bit more
in-depth Research into into the whole
process
um and so they end up exceeding the 15
days
um
I understand that's a small number of
municipalities I don't have an exact
number that's not something we'd survey
but
it is something that obviously should be
addressed because we all recognize that
the timber industry is very important
economically and is a is a major driver
of revenue for municipalities
so we want everyone to comply with the
law we understand it's 15 days we just
think that there's a better solution
than than allowing
um loggers to begin to cut and we're
happy to work on a coming to a
collective Solution on that
seeing no one else on the committee
[Music]
Miss
uh
Mr Sharp
um
Bristol and
thank you thank you for taking the time
to uh
I'm a logger fifth generation out of
Grafton County
this of course I support this bill
this is not an issue until it's an issue
um nine times out of ten
everything goes through fairly
seamlessly
I can give you a couple stories
please I do please don't oh no just a
story on how how it affects us it cost
me about four thousand dollars to move
one crew let alone multiple Crews
sometimes we're on time sensitive jobs
when I'm working for the federal
government or especially the state of
New Hampshire which I think I'm the
largest logger last year for the state
we have these towns
it's a the medium-sized hounds are the
problem the small towns they're great
take care of us wonderful even if they
don't know me
the medium-sized towns are the seem to
be the issue
I had to post a Timber tax Bond I do all
my paperwork correctly I get it in I
send one of my gentlemen down with the
check to post the bond
they sit on it and they sit on it and
they sit on it what they did not do is
they didn't sit on my check for almost
thirty thousand dollars they cash that
in two days
you're able to take care of that part of
the paperwork
this is
a problem when weather hits us
as we only work about 40 weeks out of
the year and I try to make payroll for
52.
it just is a small
issue and it's the law if they can just
do as what is in the books and it's
usually
they don't like something but it's not
one of the rules to kick it out so then
it's frustrating for myself to get a
hold of dra and they rattle the cage and
then we get it signed
and sometimes well we don't meet again
well now it's 20 days
that's a problem
but it's again
it's a problem that's easily addressed
because it's a notice and they have no
problem grabbing the tax yet last year I
paid out myself one operator
two million dollars in stumpage to
landowners which represents two hundred
thousand dollars in Timber tax to these
towns
you know I know small towns like the
town I live in they love the timber
do I have any questions
I'll ask to do any questions from
members of the committee
uh representative Darby that we're
followed by representative wolf
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm hoping you can
just briefly walk me through a typical
scenario working with a landowner to um
from the time that they contact you the
timeline in particular wondering about
the timeline from the time they contact
you to the time that you you know go
walk the property to determine you know
the cottage uh to the time that uh you
submit the form
uh first initial meet could be anywhere
is from three months out
to a year out
when it's a year out or three months out
it's not a problem it's when we have the
time sensitive
we do the forms we send them in
everything comes in plenty early sitting
in my file I have plenty of time to get
there it's when we have a weather change
and I go oh
Mr Jones said it's okay to as soon as
you can get to it Mike use it as filling
we have weather like this boom because
in in our in our intent to catch like
this time of year I have work all lined
up for April well I don't want to send
them in and file them now because it's a
new
tax year April 1st is the fiscal year
for intent to cuts
so you want to send them in now I've
done this before and they come back oh
you're going to intend to cut for the
22-23 season no I need it for 23.24 so
that starts the process again
I hope that answered your question
representative Wolf the question
if we have just a few towns and it
sounds like there are a few outliers not
a large number
would it be appropriate to just
I guess I wouldn't know that answer the
bottom line is we just want to go to
work
and I understand that too before you
excuse me I'm sorry
if you want to have a question
so you're talking about things such as
roads being posted in that no sir no I'm
talking about them not signing the
intent to cut or just trying to jam us
up time wise and there is a couple towns
out there that they are anti-logging
almost and they do anything they can to
just slow down the process
and dra has had I mean I'm on speed dial
with dra for some of these issues
because if they will not listen to us as
a logger but when dra tells them it is
State statue you have to do this well it
did answer your question yeah thanks I'm
thank you
seeing no one else
Robert Johnson
from the
foreign
Bureau correct thank you Mr chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Rob Johnson an iapa before
you represented the New Hampshire Farm
Bureau as the federation's policy
director New Hampshire Farm Bureau is
the Federation of New Hampshire's 10
County Farm Bureau organizations and we
we rep the total we represent a total of
about 3 000 member families about 1800
of those are farmer members in the
remaining 1200 or so are are supporting
members rural families like that and
we're we're very much in support of the
bill
many of uh of our of landowners have
Woodland that they they manage and
depend on for for income and you know
it's not like a normal agricultural
yearly crop where it's more of a crop
that's every decade or so and it's often
time for a larger purchase to to buy
land buy a home uh make a large
Improvement on a home or in the case of
any Farm businesses that are down year
you go to your your Woodland to try to
make up that difference and uh we we see
the the bill it as really providing some
teeth to the current statute
um that's that's that 15 uh daily choir
man but there's there are any
consequences
you know we feel as landowners that well
I've held up my end of the bar again by
filing the intent to cut the notice now
it's the responsibility of the Town Tool
let me know within 15 days that's one
and the the second benefit is that it
will it will help educate local
officials and we all know that they
change all the time but if officials
know this consequences when somebody
points out look if we don't get this
taken care of and within 15 days get
back to that landowner then they can go
they can start so it kind of gives I
guess you'd say a little bit kick in the
pants to to move things along and I just
want to stress in closing that again it
is it's been said many times this is a
notice
simply a notice and there's there's four
criteria once they're filled it should
be signed and provided to the landowner
okay I'll leave it at that and thank you
for your time and attention
any questions
seeing none
uh
good morning thank you Mr chair uh I'm
Matt Leahy I'm the public policy
director for the society for the
protection of New Hampshire Forest we
support this bill and largely for the
reasons you've already heard so I won't
repeat them here I understand there may
be a work
community on this and we would support
that too that is fine I just wanted to
take very briefly
um just kind of give you a little a
sense of you know our interest in this
bill so
um the four Society we call it for short
is a private non-profit Statewide Land
Trust which means we protect and
preserve land we were founded back in
1901 so we've been around a long time
and we own
approximately 60 000 acres in New
Hampshire spread out over 191 different
Forest reservations all over New
Hampshire and every County here in the
state
um and part of or really our
main reason why we own land and why we
protect land is to
help you know improve the Forest Health
the forest strength of you know here in
New Hampshire
um so and as part of that honestly we do
Harvest Timber from time to time we do
you know we're not a major Harvester but
we do you know maybe six to ten Harvest
a year so but it is part of our strategy
to improve the health of our forest in
this course as you've heard there's a
whole range of benefits they provide so
you know the bottom line for us is you
know we want to keep forces for us but
in actuality you know doing Harvest very
smart sustainable Harvest
you know does improve the Forest Health
and that's really
um you know our interests when we talk
about Timber harvesting but we do
support the bill
give me any questions by members of the
committee seeing not oh representative
Lamontagne
thank you Mr chair
um
it seems that an organization like yours
would spend really years having a
forestry plan to decide what areas you
are going to harvest
and I think that's
um what I'm
my difficulty with the whole process is
that the tax form I understand having
getting that last step be done with
expediency to help the logger
but
if some of the concerns that come up
with the towns have to do with the
overall bars to plan to protect the
health of the forest to protect the
Watershed that there should be some
other process that's done way in advance
and
so I'm just I don't see how this is all
going to tie in like that we should have
this final step
um be just the last check box and it
should be quick if everything else is
done ahead of time
yeah so well thanks for the question
um
and I'll try not to give along with the
answer
um but just speaking for the four
Society you know we it can take years
for us to decide whether to do a Harvest
on any one of our properties and it's
there's a very lengthy we actually have
Forest management plans for every one of
our reservations but you know if but you
know when we do reach that point
um whether or not we're going to do a
harvest I mean there are other
steps we have to go through you know you
know besides filing the intent to cut
notice I mean oftentimes there may be
Des permits we have to get those are all
you know if there's going to be a
Wetlands Crossing whatever so there's
I mean again the intent to cut you know
is
it was one part of it but there's an
awful lot that's already going on
um not just at the foresighted but many
other Forest land owners you know to to
make sure that what they're doing is is
being correctly safely smartly done and
I think
um
and again you know the the intent to cut
that's just it is the you know I'm not
gonna say it's the last step but it is
you know it's it's filed when we the
four side have already done all this
so
any other questions seeing none
thank you very much I will
uh sir Noah Edition uh seeing no uh
other pink cards
okay well no one else wishes to speak I
174.
and I will open the hearing on 194
requiring the director of the division
of archives and Records management to
compile and maintain a list of public
monuments
is it representative germanna the the
Laura is yours thank you Mr chair thank
you members of the committee uh has the
committee received the amendment that uh
should have been sent over by OLS
yesterday
they informed me uh that they were going
to do that hi
um I am not aware of anything all right
well it's a it's a simple Amendment I'll
make sure that you get it basically uh
the amendment is to change the
state agency
responsible for
compiling the list of public monuments
that I'm proposing from the records in
archive archives and Records to the
um Department of Natural and cultural
resources specifically the division of
historical resources and the director
um of that division Ben Wilson told me
that he would be emailing the chair
because he was unable to be here this
morning yes he he did I do have his uh
his memo which I will read into the
record after you've introduced The Bill
thank you Mr chair
uh so I am
um both a freshman representative uh and
also a historian and an educator and a
professor of history at Keene State
uh
and I introduced this bill because uh I
was thinking about how we could use
public monuments for educational
purposes this is something that I have a
particular kind of interested in I am
primarily uh well I am a German
historian I spent a lot of time in
Germany uh and in Germany uh public
monuments are used largely for
educational purposes of course they had
to rebuild so many monuments over the
past several decades since so many were
destroyed uh in World War II uh but they
are there to serve a particular purpose
which is educational right to engage
people right so it's not simply about
walking by something but to see what it
represents and into have some
educational function and so I was
thinking then
that it would be great if we had one
place on a State website for example
where we could find a compilation of all
of the public monuments in in the state
of New Hampshire right particularly for
educators I have a lot of friends who
are Educators uh and the idea that you
could do a class part of your New
Hampshire educational
section in a class unit or some other
type of unit perhaps where you had
middle school children picking out two
or three public monuments in your county
right to go out and to look at and to
report on as a great way to engage
uh School teachers and children in
particular with the study of the history
I think that a lot can be gained by kind
of seeing
all of the ways in which we honor uh
individuals and groups of individuals
and great events in the state I think
that having one list gives us the
opportunity to see who's represented all
across our state who isn't represented
and to have discussions about perhaps
who should be right and and how they're
represented so I introduced this bill
being very new I made a mistake I wasn't
I didn't know which department uh it
should go to I'm a historian so I
thought about the archives archives keep
these kinds of Records but I had a great
conversation with representative rung uh
and then I reached out to the Secretary
of State's office and spoke with the
deputy secretary of state who advised me
then to speak to the folks at the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
which I did I've been working with the
director of the division of historical
resources Ben Wilson
to craft the language for an amendment
that would would move this from archives
and Records to uh to his division uh and
he assures me that they have the
resources already to be able to do this
it would it would involve having
somebody who already Works in that
division
work with local historical societies and
other organizations within communities
around the state to compile lists which
largely would come in from those local
organizations
so that was the the reason why I
uh proposed the bill in the first place
think about how we could use public
monuments to create a richer discussion
about our state's history particularly
among school children but ideally for
all of us and the reason for the
amendment is because
in my uh in my greenness I was not clear
about which state department you know
Department within the state would be
best to handle
this project so I think that's a brief
outline and I'm very happy to take
any questions by members of the
committee
representative haribolia
so thank you very much for taking my
question so
it says fiscal note but you said that it
won't require any extra costs is that
correct thank you yes that is that is
correct
director Wilson in our conversations
told me that it would not incur any
extra cost so when the amendment comes
forward and I apologize that you don't
have it today I was told that that it
would be ready for today but you'll see
that there is not a physical note
attached
yeah
so yeah we normally we do get uh
we do get the amendment but uh
is there
says so there's no other no one else
speak out speaking Noel no one else uh
no questions
uh
if if not thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh I do want to read for the
record uh it was it was sent to me like
uh well
4 30 last night uh
it is from uh Ben Ben Wilson director of
the New Hampshire division
of historical resources State historic
preservation officer
uh and his part of
the division he is the division of uh
head of the division of historic
resources it is a high representative
renzullo tomorrow
Wednesday the 18th your committee will
be conducting a hearing regarding House
Bill 194 which establishes a list of all
state historic monuments and markers I
can't attend the hearing but want the
committee to know that I and the
division of historic resources DHR
support this bill
I have worked with the sponsor on the
language and feel that we can accomplish
what the bill sets out to do without
burdening DHR staff or committing
Financial Resources also feel free to
read the state this statement onto the
into the record
indefinitely if you or or the committee
have questions of me please do not
hesitate to reach out my best Ben and
that so that'll be in the record I'll uh
I'll send it uh I'll send it there I'll
send it to everyone on the committee
[Music]
is there any uh do not
I do have oh yeah
194 representative uh Peter petrigno
I should be able to as my name like a
renzullo I should be able to test to
pronounce that a little bit better thank
you Mr chairman I appreciate that and
thank you members of the committee I'm
representative Peter Petrino from
Hillsboro 43 the town of Milford uh
prior to my arrival here as a
representative I was a high school
social studies teacher and department
chair for many years my students
participated in National History Day
it's not one day but a yale-long study
on the pot of high school and middle
school students
focusing on a theme
creating a Project based on intense
research and critical analysis
and as such when their projects are
completed they compete with other high
schools throughout the state of New
Hampshire at Plymouth State University
the winners then go on to the University
of Maryland and the Smithsonian American
History Museum where they compete with
students from all across the country
I'm proud to say that my students have
done well in the past but they are at a
disadvantage when they compete against
students from large states that also
have greater resources at their disposal
so I'm here to speak in support of 194
because I believe it will be just one
more tool that our students can use when
they compete in this wonderful program
that's it and I'm happy to take any
questions
any questions from members of the
committee
thank you representative Petrino thank
okay seeing is
seeing no other
uh no other pink cards
uh
we'll close the hearing on House Bill
1 141 relative to dogs on hiking trails
and state parks
uh
representative Harrington
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee
um we try to make this brief because I
know we're running a little late here
but uh this is a bill that basically has
three parts to it uh three reasons for
it common sense safety and I'll also
address enforcement uh just as a brief
way of background so you'll have some
idea that I do have some idea of what
I'm talking about on this I've been
hiking in New Hampshire for probably
about 40 years about 12 15 or so of
those anyways I've been accompanied by a
dog in that 40 Years of hiking I have
never run into a problem with the dog
being off a leash uh and like I say
that's hundreds and hundreds of hikes I
was a trip leader for the YMCA Alpine
club for 15 years and led hikes for them
I never run into people who have said oh
we had a real problem last week because
there was a dog off of a leash on a
hiking trail so the best I can tell is
there's a problem it doesn't exist and
so you don't think that's simply my
opinion all back that up with something
else two major things the largest area
of hiking trails in New Hampshire of
course is the White Mountains National
Forest they get visited by I think the
amounts at least in the hundreds of
thousands of people uh every year
their policy is dogs are not allowed on
leash not required to be on leashes
except in a few very select special
areas that see large degree of travel
one I think is like Dana's baths in
Conway off of West Side Road you'll see
that in July and August because it's
literally Bumper to Bumper people
walking on that but that's the very much
the exception not the rule so the over
almost I would say 99 plus of the White
Mountains National Forest if you're on a
hiking trail you don't need to have your
dog on a leash it has to be under your
control another very large area used and
I'll just read from the publication here
for a second and see Belknap range in
New Hampshire which is an extensive
hiking range that deals in the middle of
the state it runs from Mount Major over
to the gun stock area and you may note
Mount Major is one of the most hyped
mountains in New Hampshire if you go up
there in say the end of September on a
Saturday you will not find a parking
spot they have hundreds of miles of
hiking trails and they just simply say
dogs are welcome but must be must retain
under the control of the owners there's
no requirement for them to have a leash
on it at all times so we look at what my
bill would do it simply says
that if you're on a hiking trail
and
your dog needs to be under the control
of the owner the owner has to carry a
leash in case it became necessary to
restrain the dog
um if it's crossing a campground a
picnic area parking lots any area where
vehicles are required uh rest areas then
the dog would have to be on a leash in
those areas now the state has a very
extensive list of
somewhat confusing rules and it's
multiple pages of these on where you can
take a dog and where you can't some
areas they're banned completely but one
is clear it must be on a leash at all
times any place in a state park that's
the present rule
um there are certain Parks like
manadnock State Park which I'm assuming
the reason is because it's very crowded
that dogs aren't allowed at all uh the
obvious reasons Hampton Beach State Park
there's no hiking trails there anyways
uh odion same thing
um they're prohibited and this is a
little this gets a little funny some of
this is the pets are prohibited
seasonally at Pawtuckaway State Park
beaches which again my bill wouldn't
affect a designated swim areas picnic
areas Pavilions and group view series
all of those would already be exempt
from the requirement to allow dogs off
of leashes
um and another one is red I find rather
the button uh if you look at the
Parts with with pet restrictions for
inconia State Park which is I think most
people know where that is up in
Franconia Notch it's again I just read a
thing in the paper it's one of the uh
most looked up state parks in the
country but uh Franconia State Park dogs
only permitted on hiking trails and
designated walk area only again my bill
would would not change that other than
that they wouldn't have to have a leash
on the hiking trails now the reason I
bring that up is maybe you have I have
not been there but if you go to
Franconia United State Park you start
hiking up to the kinsmens you walk along
a trail and you start to gain elevation
and eventually you come to a sign that
says entering White Mountains National
Forest now once you pass that sign is no
longer required to keep the dog on a
leash once you step backwards it's
required to me that's silly if it's if
it's a good reason to have it then it
should be throughout and the fact that
the White Mountains has for years and
years and years not required leashes on
dogs tells me that not having leashes on
dogs is not a problem the same thing
with the belt map range I don't know why
the the state feels it's necessary to
keep these dogs on leashes but again I
will reiterate in the hundreds of hikes
that I've had in hundreds and hundreds
of hikers I've spoke to not once has
anyone ever come up to me and said boy
we had a problem with a dog wasn't on a
leash and remember my bill also says You
must carry a leash so if you somehow you
ran into an aggressive dog you could
control your dog physically if necessary
just is that a common courtesy when I
hike I always ask when I see someone
coming are you okay with dogs 99.9
percent of the time they say no if they
say yes I tell the dog to sit which he's
already done put a leash on him and make
sure he doesn't get any other person
that's just common courtesy we don't
need to put that in the laws
so
there's again I say there's there seems
to be no reason to have dogs on leashes
except in for some reason in the state
park maybe 40 years ago there was an
incident in a state park I don't know
but I do know that there's been no
problems in the White Mountains National
Forex or in the Belk map range which are
extensive miles of hiking trails I mean
literally thousands of miles when you
put them all together so that's the
common sense of uh approach the second
thing is a safety factor and the reason
I say it's safety factor is I'll just
take for example yesterday I was hiking
in Pawtuckaway State Park on the back
side of the park where most was a lot of
hiking North Mountain you can get over
to the forest Tower you cannot safely
hike with a dog on those trails and the
reason being is if you're going up or
down a hill especially if it's steep
especially in the winter time you cannot
do it with a dog if you tried going
especially going downhill if you're
going downhill with a dog on a leash
unless the dog weighs like five or six
pounds you are not going to go the same
way the dog does you may have crampons
on snowshoes they're going to have four
feet you're going to have two and you're
that's an accident that's waiting to
happen because if the dog pulls you one
way and you pull the other someone's
gonna go down and get hurt so it simply
isn't safe to do it and so just just
think about that for a second if you're
coming down to fairly steep section
especially in the winter it's it's just
simply not safe to have a dog on a leash
it's not confined just to the Winter
though think about your crossing a
stream you're trying to go across the
stream now you're going to be jumping
from rock to rock or walking on a fallen
log the dog is just going to plow
through the water it simply doesn't work
what I do when I especially when I lead
groups is I have my dog with me is I'll
have them cross the stream first go on
the other side and wait therefore he
doesn't interfere with anybody else
because everyone else is trying to make
sure they don't fall in the water and
they don't want to be bumped by a dog
who's running across so it's really a
safety factor I mean if you're saying
you have to have a dog on a leash at all
times then you're saying dogs should not
be allowed in any place where there's
any elevation gang a loss or any streams
to cross because it simply is not safe
to do so
the last Factor I'll mention is
enforcement because you might hear
something about this how are we going to
enforce the law how is it we're going to
be able to see if the dog is under
someone's control if they're not
physically on a leash
well again that doesn't seem to be a
problem in the White Mountains it
doesn't seem to be a problem in the
Belknap range because they don't require
a leash but even that is a red herring
because the this will be enforced
exactly the same way the law is enforced
now and that is it will not be enforced
on all those hundreds of hikes I've told
you on we go to there's a park called
Northwood Meadows which is only a few
miles from my house and it's a state
park and it says dogs must be on leashes
and my latest dog is eight years old and
we probably average one day a week going
over there anyways never in those
hundreds of trips over there over the
last eight years am I seeing a single
Park employee on a hiking trail not one
it wasn't like this would be weekends
holidays weekdays weekdays mornings
afternoons not a single one we also
frequent Pawtuckaway State Park a lot I
used to go there to do a lot of climbing
I'm getting a little bit too old for
that now but I still do a lot of hiking
we come in through the reservation
roadside or the Round Pond Side where
there's there's no Gates there's no
admission charge whatever you just park
and go hiking again I have never seen a
Park employee on those and even going up
to the more common used places like
where the forest Tower is in Pawtuckaway
never seeing a Park employee on a hiking
trail so it isn't an Enforcement issue
because it's not enforced now so I'm
just asking bring a little common sense
it gives an exception in the law it says
that there's areas like an ad knock
State Park which they must I'm assuming
they deem because of crowded that they a
park Department could post and say if it
you know if it has unique conditions
with such as high pedestrian traffic the
department shell posts such trails with
signage that that indicate that all dogs
must be leased so again Common Sense
safety and don't listen to any argument
about enforcement because that's totally
a red herring and I'd be glad to take
thank you is there any questions by
representative wrong thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question representative
um are you concerned about any Hazard or
damage a dog may cause if if it's
um you mean like actually like to
Wildlife or something like that or
nesting areas Wildlife maybe there's
some sensitive areas off Trail an
Unleashed dog going into those areas and
causing damage
well again all I can say is I've never
heard of that being an issue and again I
go back to the White Mountains National
Forest which is many times larger than
our state park systems and they do not
think that's an issue and I rely on
their Wildlife biologists because they
don't stop you from having a dog not on
a leash so I assume they must think it's
not an issue so I have to say no it's
not an issue okay thank you
any other questions by members of the
committee
representative Gould yes thank you for
uh taking my question I'm not quite sure
how to did you say that uh
uh dogs on list leashes are not a
problem
dogs off leashes are not a problem dogs
on leashes are not a problem I haven't
seen any problems with dogs one way or
the other
to be quite honest the most aggressive
dogs that people that I've run into and
like I say I go let's do this all the
time our dog's on leashes they tend to
be on leashes and I think dogs have a
situation where there's sort of a fight
or flight and since they can't run away
because they're on a leash those are the
ones that tend to growl the most but
it's you generally rely on the owner and
I like I say this is years and years of
taking a dog hiking and simply asking a
simple question is your dog okay with
other dogs and if they say no then we
make sure both parties make sure the
dogs stay separate and you know for the
most part they say yes and all they want
to do is play and sniff bums I mean
yeah
anyone else representative Darby
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question sorry but you see
right we're blocked there
um you mentioned that uh you know
obviously you hike a lot and you've seen
a lot of dogs off leash because like you
said um people aren't following the
current law
um are are these dogs that you've seen
off leash are they under control
um would you what you would consider
control and how far ahead of the
um you know of their owners are they
typically
most almost all the time the dogs are
with the owner and they're fairly close
and that's why we're able to take
advantage of that by saying you'll see
somebody coming and you simply ask the
question is the dog get along with other
dogs
um two days ago we were over in
Northwood and it was my dog was off
leash he was close to me and there was a
woman quite a ways down and she saw her
up and she just said okay my dog doesn't
like other dogs so I told my dog to sit
I put a leash on him she walked over to
one side I walked over the other side
and we walked by the only time I've
really seen a dog uh away from its owner
for an extended period of time we were
hiking in the White Mountains we were
staying overnight at a shelter we get in
around five o'clock it was the summer
time and it's just always remember this
because it's kind of funny this very
large Saint Bernard like 150 pounds
showed up came over and plumped itself
down next to us and we gave him some
water we gave him some food we didn't
know where he came from because there
was multiple Trails going back so we
couldn't really backtrack and about an
hour and a half two hours later two
people showed up one of them had twisted
their ankle it was going really slow
that's as long as I've seen a dog and
the dog didn't do anything except sit
there and didn't eat so it was it was
not an issue I just think it's most
people show common sense and the fact
that we've had years and years and years
in the belt map range in in South which
is the southeast Land Trust doesn't
require a leash and in the White
Mountains tell us that this simply isn't
an issue because if people were getting
attacked by dogs or dogs were attacking
other dogs in the White Mountains they
would quickly do something about it it's
thank you
anyone else
representative
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
um my my two labs for their 13 Years
love to roam the trails specifically
horse Health Nature Preserve
the operative word being horse we had a
horse farm near us or a horse uh Paddock
near us
and they loved people and the question
is and the question is have you spoken
any horse owners I'll ask it for I think
uh representative vale's not not around
here
have you spoken to any horse users or
questions well actually not specifically
but I did get a couple of emails sort of
out of the blue on the bill by by one
woman who said she likes to go with her
horse and her dog and she was in favor
of the bill a common sense would tell me
that if I see someone and once in a
while you do see horses it's not that
common in New Hampshire but there are
some parks we used to you run into some
Trails if I see the door my horse coming
I'm going to put the dog on a leash and
again that you are required to have a
leash with this and that's just pure
safety because you don't want the dog
going up and barking at the horse which
could toss the rider and I don't want
the Taurus kicking the dog because let's
face it they're a lot bigger than dogs
so again you're required to carry a
leash with you just for situations like
that as unusual as they are you'd be
covered you could see the horse coming
put the dog on the leash and make sure
there was no harmful interaction
thank you
you anyone else
seeing no one thank you very much thank
you for having me thank you uh Brian
Laura good morning chairman and
committee members uh my name is Brian
Wilson I'm the director of New Hampshire
state parks it's a pleasure
being here this morning and talking
about dogs
um I'd like to provide the following
testimony please accept this testimony
on behalf of the Department of Natural
and cultural resources division of Parks
and Recreation regarding HB 141 relative
to dogs on hiking trails in state parks
the division appreciates the concerns of
the Bill's sponsor but we respectfully
provide the committee with the following
information the division already allows
dogs off leash and under the control of
their Handler under current
administrative rules
pursuant to Department administrative
rules
730108 and except for State Park areas
where dogs are prohibited year-round of
which there are only four state parks
um in remote areas dogs shall be
permitted off leash and under the
control of their handlers in accordance
with RSA 466 30A provided that the dog
is not or does not become a menace a
nuisance or vicious as defined in RSA
46631 under which the owner or the
Handover Handler shall restrain leash
and remove the dog from the property
for the purposes of this section remote
areas means those areas and trails where
and during a time when the dog owner or
Handler and the dog will not come into
contact with other users and the dog
owner or Handler shall leash and Leash
the dog when other users are present our
ability to tailor our administrative
rules on animals and state parks allows
for changes over time based on
communities Trends and other factors
such as development and improvements to
the parks visitation levels and other
natural resource management
considerations thank you for the
opportunity to provide the testimony on
this bill we hope that the existing
administrative rules that allows dogs to
be off leash and under the control of
their Handler addressed as the concerned
concerns of the Bill's sponsors and
therefore hb-141 is not necessary
is there any questions by members of the
committee
representative
thank you Mr chair um so my question is
that the I'm assuming that the penalty
for a dog off off leash in a yeah in the
other zones is a fine do we have any
sense of of how many of those were
issued last year or the year before
um
just to give us an idea of how often
this is this is occurring
um so uh we do not actually issue uh
fines uh where we're
um the the rule is uh to
um in this particular case would be to
to lease your dog and leave the premises
um so that would be under the the
enforcement action
um really would be a pretty light touch
of uh of uh just a an account with if
they were to run into a park staff but
we're not actually issuing fines on this
thank you
you finished
representative
no representative Gould do you have a
question no oh okay you got your mic on
it oh okay
representative Dunn
um I've been asked to present this on
the website it says that all animals
must be on a standard or retractable
leash not greater than six feet in
length
um is that uh
from our from our website then yes I
would imagine that yes our our website
and finally Mr Paul uh
is it
Severson
Nickerson okay
all right sorry about the left-handed
reading
so
no microphone
push spit around there yeah there you go
is it clear now oh yeah very
my testimony is very brief so I'm going
to read it we oppose this bill for a lot
of reasons
not the least of which is that keeping
dogs under control is kind of a nebulous
concept
and it's in the eye of the beholder and
the further out they are from not being
under control the more damage they'll do
so
dog owners are unlikely to restrict
their animals to a trail proper and may
allow them to explore both sides of a
trail while allegedly within verbal
control
such exploration presents risks to
Native Wildlife especially during the
nesting season
Brown nesting Birds including game birds
like rough Grouse Woodcock and wild
turkey as well as non-game species such
as hermit thrush and oven bird are
vulnerable to Nest failure triggered by
curious dogs
are also known to capture young birds
not able to fly well
now if any of you are hunters even in
October if you if you've hunted with
dogs and you wonder if they chase
Wildlife or not all you got to do is
remember the day when your dog got a
nose full of porcupine quills so we know
they chase wildlife other times you've
probably seen if you were hunting birds
you've probably seen them chasing
rabbits so it's not as easily definable
as one might think in terms of wildlife
impacts
now our stated Mission or the State
admission of the division of Parks and
Recreation is to provide New Hampshire
citizens and guests with outstanding
recreational educational and
inspirational experience now I'm going
to emphasize through the responsible
management and Cooperative stewardship
of the state's natural recreational and
cultural resources
allowing Unleashed dogs in state parks
does not constitute responsible
management of the state's natural
resources we urge you to vote H.B 141 in
expedient to legislate police
thank you I'm done is there any
seeing none
thank you very much for your testimony
there anyone else who wishes to
oh to speak I uh we have so I have the
last of my pink parts
seeing none
I will
close the hearing and house bill 141.
and open the hearing on
I'll spill for 34.
representative post I presume you're
going to be
if we be presenting the bill
and welcome back to the committee
thank you it's so nice to see everybody
and see all the new faces on here
um I do miss it already I do I do it's a
good committee you must all be having
fun
um and also good good things about the
dogs I I love to hike too and
I I do off leash with my dog and he
stays very close so we don't have a
problem
um so good morning
um Mr chairman and the committee I
appreciate your hearing me today
I'm representative Lisa post I'm from
Hillsborough District 42 which covers
lineborough Mount Vernon New Boston and
I'm happy to introduce today house bill
434fn
as many of you may remember
this bill came before us last
term and
the bill before you now has changed
quite a bit
and
the difference with this spill from the
other bill
is a whole host of changes and one of
the main
reasons for it to be a diversion from
the last bill because it only applies to
state parks and not the Statewide trail
system
we have drew McCallum here and I'd like
to bring him up after my testimony to
come and speak to all the nitty-gritty
of this bill because it has changed a
lot and the FAA isn't involved anymore
and it
uh is a good thing I think to put this
forth and allow people to use it
commercially and recreationally
um in the Parks
this bill allows for the commercial and
recreational use of drones
or small unmanned aircraft in state
parks subject to exceptions and
limitations the bill also establishes
fees and authorizes fines to be assessed
for violations
this again is a constituent bill
and I am proud to be able to support our
constituents in the legislature and I'd
like to bring them up to address the
committee there are before I end this I
do have the fiscal note
um that you probably have the bill but
that shows that that there are fines for
up to 25 fees for up to 25 a day and for
drone violations where things occur
there will be fines assessed and it is
an in in in German blah blah blah
indeterminable
um amount uh for them to project since
this hasn't been allowed before
so with that
um could we have Mr mckellick come up
here
right so he is has
the basic knowledge and it was part of
the creation of the bill yes okay I'll
I'll allow that where is he thank you Mr
McCallum right here okay would you want
to stay with him or I do you wish okay
just so I can enjoy that
all right
in the
Jew
says well
identify yourself and uh what your
relationship is with the
uh with the with this spill
thank you Mr chairman for once again
giving me the opportunity to speak
before this committee my name is sterma
calma I'm from Hollis New Hampshire and
um I contacted representative post over
the past couple months to resubmit a
similar Bill to what you saw last year
um I work as a data scientist for IBM
and I'm from a family of Pilots my dad
is a pilot my younger brothers are
pilots my grandfather was a pilot my
uncle's a pilot many extended family
members who are pilots
I've been a licensed private pilot since
the age of 22 and I soloed in gliders
when I was 16 years old
since I was about eight years old I have
been flying remote controlled aircraft
and this is now referred to as drone
piloting
about three years ago the state park
system banned drone launches and
landings without establishing a
straightforward permitting process which
I believe is an undue burden on drone
users
I testified in front of this committee
exactly a year ago on a similar bill
which was HB 1292 in the 2022 session
that bill was itl by this committee on
several technicalities which gave me and
several other drone Pilots the
opportunity to take feedback from this
committee and other community members to
submit a greatly improved bill on this
session I specifically want to thank
Maurice apienza my friend who's a lawyer
and former State Rep from Newton
Junction for legal advice and support on
this bill she takes amazing photos from
both the land and above with her drone
I also want to thank Vic moss and Kenji
sugahara they're both nationally
recognized Rowan attorneys for the Drone
service providers Alliance
who helped me revise this bill multiple
times and ultimately give me their stamp
of approval
and lastly I want to thank
representative Lisa post again for
submitting the spell on my behalf
so here are some of the big improvements
in this bill from last year's bill as
representative post mentioned this
applies to only state parks and not the
state park Statewide trail system since
the ladder would require rewriting
easement agreements with landowners per
this committee's feedback
number two uh pilot education
requirements for both commercial and
recreational Pilots is now in the bill
which again was another suggestion from
this committee
uh three this drops the permission
requirement in the previous bill which
parallels the policy of the White
Mountain National Forest so again like
the dog bill you heard before we want to
keep the policies very similar what
works in the white national uh
National Forest should probably also
work just fine in state parks
for this fixes several state and federal
overlap of rules there's already a
robust set of federal rules about when
and where you can fly recreational
Pilots are never allowed to fly drones
over people and commercial pilots have
very strict rules no drones are allowed
to over fly over open air Assemblies of
people so no crowds of people no matter
what
five commercial permits the state can
collect a fee from commercial users
again paralleling the White Mountain
National Forest
six this bill bans drone use at The
Flume gorge in peak season as well as
Canon Mountain during ski operating
hours so that was another suggestion I
believe from one of the Commissioners in
their testimony last year and lastly
seven we added a clause that prohibits
flights that would interfere with the
reasonable enjoyment of the park by
other users
and some of the other testimonies last
year there was talk about the disruption
that drones would cause the state parks
already have significant disruptions due
to overcrowding of people if there were
true concern for disruptions the state
park system should do more to limit the
number of people in the Parks and on the
trails rather than have an unreasonable
drone ban I have a picture in my written
testimony showing artist Bluff on
Columbus Day weekend last year and you
can see there's hundreds of people there
and they can do a lot more to limit the
amount of parking but I think going
after drones trying to to fix the issues
uh it doesn't work
people are already ignoring the Drone
ban and flying anyways uh recently I
counted over 30 YouTube videos of drones
flying in Crawford Notch State Park
alone
so wouldn't it be better to have a drone
flying in state parks sanctioned with
reasonable rules and regulations
a number of points I made last year I
spoke about hunting which is permitted
in state parks and does cause multiple
deaths in New Hampshire each year and
again drones are much much safer than
hunting I've known of no incidents in
New Hampshire that would be reason to
cause us to have strict rules against
having drones
it's a great marketing opportunity for
the state so you can have more social
media presence
and this is also good for children
interested in stem Fields so there's a
group of fourth graders visiting from
Plymouth right behind me they are the
future we got to do this for them we got
to keep these opportunities open for
aerial videography is a popular medium
today and it allows more people to
access scenery who otherwise wouldn't be
able to
so it's an accessibility issue as well
this is an excellent bill that was well
vetted by multiple attorneys and other
drone stakeholders and I asked the
committee to give this bill a not to
pass recommendation I'd be happy to
answer questions thank you Mr chairman
any questions by members of the
committee
representative wrong thank you Mr
chairman representative wolf and thank
you for taking my question I want to
follow up on a comment I want to make
sure I heard it correctly when you were
referencing the number of people using
the state parks and crowds were you
suggesting that the state limit the
number of people of state parks to
accommodate people who want to use
drones no I'm saying
if there's concern about disrupting
wildlife and disrupting the natural
state of the Wilderness whatever there
should be more done to limit the crowds
rather than have a blanket rule Against
drones
representative wolf question
thank you Mr chairman you uh
specifically excluded Cannon Mountain
during the ski area
I happen to live next to Mount Sunapee
uh would that be one that would be
banned during the ski season even though
it is leased out I don't know the terms
of the least but I assume they have
control over that and they currently do
not allow drones at Mount Sunapee under
their lease
anyone else
okay
[Music]
representative Darby then representative
Harvey bolia
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for taking my question uh where
would you uh foresee uh launching these
drones from and Landing them
adjacent to Trails that aren't being
heavily utilized
um there's a lot of wilderness areas
that
you could hike to and this fits right in
the backpack
so you could take it you could get some
nice photos once you get above the trees
so it'd be like open areas it wouldn't
be congested areas where there's a lot
of people
um and you would have to have a nice
landing site that's not too wooded
representative Harvey Bowie for a
question
thank you very much chair
um one quick one question then perhaps a
follow-up but
um to piggyback on that question about
takeoff
um as a I've got my certified uas
license uh
license
um and I've flown drones
uh does this and I'm sorry I don't have
I didn't get a copy of the bill in my
packet if you have an extra one I
wouldn't mind it
um the takeoff I know uh from experience
that if a drone is uh launched near cars
or Metals anything metal thank you
um that it can malfunction because this
actually happened to me
um when launching from a parking lot
um
and it the metal from the cars can
interfere with the Drone the software
and the Drone and what happened was I
was flying it and then suddenly my
controller was unresponsive and it flew
into a tree
uh luckily nobody was hurt but
it was pretty uh alarming so
um does your bill speak to that at all
yes it does okay um there's a section in
there I don't have the bill right in
front of me but there is a section about
but it doesn't prohibit the it it
doesn't prohibit people from launching
in a parking in the parking lot does it
it does not but there are there are
plenty of rules I'm at the federal level
that do cover uh flight safety and if
it's not a safer to fly
there's there's plenty of uh FAA for
ours said
Reddit uh flying in bad areas okay um
one other question for a follow-up
follow-up last one and as far as now
somebody mentioned Cannon Mountain and
one of the issues with drones is
obviously you can with the new ones you
can set them to follow and track people
um which oftentimes is you know it's
your own drone and you want the Drone to
follow you down the ski mountain and
film yourself skiing and that's what my
understanding is why they're prohibited
in ski areas
um is there anything in your bill that
kind of speaks to I think I did see it
but if you could clarify how you can you
people don't want to be tracked
obviously unless they've given
permission so
correct yeah there's a clause at the end
that describes
um getting written permission if you are
trying to loiter and track a certain
person and that parallels the language
that was written into
um the current law regarding spying on
people hunting
okay any other mem any other members of
of Representative Kelly
so I'm just doing playback to last year
so My my language about the the 25 fee
um assessed by the department
for commercial use I just think that a
ranger or somebody in the park is going
to have difficulty no no distinguishing
commercial use versus like you're you
yourself are a drone pilot I assume that
you you know offer services at some
level
um a single person it's not like a film
crew from a from a movie where it's
obvious that this is commercial use it
can be difficult to distinguish between
recreational and commercial use so the I
believe the language in last year's bill
so that it was the responsibility of the
pilot to assess to to pay the or to
notify the department and pay the fee or
we at least had discussion about that I
don't know if it was actually in the
bill so my my we made a change to the
bill
um that made it the Pilot's
responsibility to say that they're doing
it for commercial use would you you
in favor of that
yeah I'm in favor that's how it's
currently written it is up to the pilot
to determine that because as a
commercial pilot I can fly this I can
fly the Drone recreationally just for my
own enjoyment that's what I do most of
the time it is a picture of my own my
own fun
um
but you know it parallels the policy in
the White Mountain National Forest they
have the same system as well it's up to
the the pilot to determine what the the
use is and it's kind of the honor System
to determine
um whether or not they should pay the
fee
representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman I'm also a
recreational drone pilot until I've
drowned mine off the back of the boat
um so I've been thinking about replacing
it does your bill address different
restrictions different sizes from the
small little mavic to the Phantom to the
big agris and octocopters all the
different DJI the the little ones the
big ones because you know some are tiny
little pocket ones and then some are
much more invasive and annoying to the
average hiker
yeah that's kind of out of the
jurisdiction in the state that's up to
the FAA to come up with a lot of the
regulations as far as what's flying in
the airspace uh State can only really
control what's launching and landing on
on state lands and
it really it's just going to be people
that have small drones and backpacks for
the most part
the really expensive big drones I mean
it just
yeah they're probably more of a nuisance
but there's just not that many of them
and this really limited to large-scale
film Crews that are going to be using
something that's going to be
so so the one you have there is like a
mavic air and that's like the most
common
that the average tourist or the that
this bill would pertain to correct yeah
DJI makes a drone that's a little bit
bigger than this but it's really not
going to be anything bigger than like
Yay big it's
um generally going to be backpack size
drones
for a follow-up thank you
and that's limited to less than 400 feet
correct correct above ground level
thank you
any more questions from the from the
board
who made it
seeing none thank you very much
Mr Wilson the chair is your the floor is
yours
well good afternoon now I can say
chairman and and
committee members thank you very much
please accept the following testimony on
behalf of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources division of Parks and
Recreation I'm sorry I will introduce
myself again Brian Wilson director of
New Hampshire state parks
um please accept the testimony on behalf
of the Department of Natural and
cultural resources division of Parks and
Recreation regarding HB 434 relative to
drones in state parks we respectfully
provide the committee with the following
information we are very concerned with
the impact of this bill would have on
the recreational experience of our
visitors and state parks campgrounds and
trails including those Trails across
private land protecting the quality of
that experience is one of the purposes
of our administrative rules
impacts of drones on Recreation
recreationalists we are concerns that
drone use on lands owned by the state
will negatively impact other
recreational users who are otherwise
expecting to be able to enjoy a quiet
experience in Parks campgrounds and
trails our administrative rules
governing the use of Department lands
State the following restrictions in
public use dncr Properties or portions
of a property shall be closed or
restricted for Public Access by posting
and or by public notification
by authorized dncr Personnel if the
quiet enjoyment of the recreational use
of the property by others or abutting
landowners is being disturbed
um additionally
um reserved and privileged use of dread
lands and facilities and resources also
addresses visitor experience
degradation of the visitor experience
means the event activity or use disrupts
disrupts traditional Park use or unduly
inconveniences abutting landowners or
the general public and clauses or might
cause any of the following conditions
impose on or conflict with the conflict
with the use of dreadlands facilities
and Resources by the public at Large
um excessive noise so as to not deny
others the right to quiet enjoyment of
their recreational use of dreadlands
facilities and resources or multiple
complaints by other visitors or parties
as determined by the department
although the bill prohibits flights that
intentionally interfere with the
reasonable use and enjoyment of the park
by other visitors the definition of this
provision is unclear and unenforceable
the bill also prohibits the use of
drones with the intent to conduct video
surveillance of private citizens and we
believe that that provision is also
unenforceable unenforceable and that a
visitor's privacy could be
unintentionally impacted
loss of recreational access we are
dependent on the willingness of private
landowners to allow trails in the
Statewide trail system to cross their
lands for public use we are very
concerned that those landowners would no
longer permit the public use of their
property if they were required to allow
drone uses on Trails they owned and
drone use would not
drone users would not know when they
have crossed onto privately owned lands
commercial use lastly we already have a
process for granting commercial use of
drones by issuance of a special use
permit under administrative rules
special use means any event activity or
use that is beyond the normal or routine
recreational use of a specific
dread property or an event activity or
other use requiring a permit
permits enable the department to
effectively manage the use of drones
while protecting the concerns of private
landowners who open their trails to the
public the visitor experience and
privacy of citizens thank you for the
opportunity to provide the testimony and
pertinent information related to HB 434
please let me know if I can answer any
questions or provide any additional
information
any questions from the committee
oh
okay
all right representative gold followed
by representative Horgan
asked this question sooner but our
yes uh follow-up please for a follow-up
um I could not answer that question I I
think it's something that you can you
can hear if it's obviously the lower it
is or the larger the Drone is I think
um uh more the closer the proximity to
people if you you would hear it um if
it's 400 feet in the air it's probably
pretty unlikely or perhaps
not very noticeable thank you
representative Horton no
anyone else
representative Lamontagne and then
representative Darby for following
yes thank you
um
and the testimony submitted
um it says the bill was improved upon by
applying only to state parks and not the
Statewide trail system
um but aren't most Trails don't they
originate in state parks and how would
you
split
um
how could you define that differently I
don't see that in your testimony or in
the bill so yes there are a large most
all of our state parks have Trail
networks with within the parks
um so
um it would be really impossible to
separate drone use within a park from
from trail trail users within a park
there is Trail networks
managed outside of State ownership as
part of our Bureau of trails for
primarily for ATV and
ohrv usage which some is owned by the
state but much of it is private land
ownership and some of it is
um it it gets very tricky to know you
know if you're on a trail Corridor at
times whether you're on private property
or state property or otherwise
representative representative Darby for
a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um the bill states that there was a
couple of places but yeah um where if
the
um where if the Drone comes down and
it's not cannot be retrieved by the
um by launcher then there's a retrieval
fee of a hundred dollars whether I think
that's both if it's lands from outside
the park and I thought I saw some place
it's
basically if it's if it can't be
accessed it's not going to cost the 100
to retrieve it but um does that do you
would you
um read that that it requires the
um State Park
um system to retrieve it for them for a
hundred dollars even if that might
require more than a hundred dollars to
access it
in labor or just to get it right
um thank you I'm just gonna just
reference the the language here so I can
try to respond to that
um so I I read that as may be fined by
the commissioner so that that
um May affords us the the ability to do
so or not or or not is that the question
sorry my question was like so you you
wouldn't read that like you have to
retrieve it um for a hundred dollars
any other questions
representative Veil
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um would there be some kind of a
liability for retrieving a drone if it
was needed to be so what I'm learning
about drones
I'm gonna
pretend I don't know anything it could
be very small it could be very big it
could be up in the sky very high it
could be down very low it could get
stuck somewhere the
um the park system could fetch it for a
hundred dollars
fee but is there liability for managing
somebody else's equipment I mean once
it's down who owns it
if it's on state property is it owned by
the land are these items insured I mean
what is the state's position on managing
these kinds of vehicles because it is a
vehicle as far as I know
um I think that anything that is Left
Behind or unretrieved is is considered
um litter essentially
regardless of of of its uh operability
um and our our staff would have to take
a uh you know an informed approach as to
whether
um it's it's
viable to even you know retrieve it if
it's you know underwater or an
inaccessible or dangerous location that
wouldn't be something that we would seek
any other questions by members of the
committee
this anybody
seeing none
thank you this I thought I saw a move
pardon
I'm not sure but sure why not try it
try it you'll like it
I'm wondering about
flyer can be given
a license like a hunter
to fly a drone
and that you could set a limit on the
number of
drone Pilots
seasonally
or something along those lines to
hobby profession
myth was our question questions about
license I guess yeah you you may want I
don't know we do have somebody from the
Bureau of uh dot Bureau of Aeronautics
might be able to answer that question a
little bit better well when she comes up
I'm getting a yes so save it save that
question so I I will I'll you know what
I can say is that we currently do allow
through our special use perm permit
process
um consideration for for commercial use
so we we can and and do allow that and
and entertain uh those uses and permit
those uses I think the recreational com
side of it it would be a
speculative to to Really gauge you know
what the the interest level would be and
and how to uh to to manage that
appropriately
okay uh see no more questions someone
looking to question I will uh you know
thank you I'll ask you to
uh let's see Kate
sheets uh you support the bill
uh had not put down the way you want us
you're not looking to speak
because I there was a card
submitted and you if not I'll just go on
but
you'd have to use the microphone so it
hi hi my name is Kate sheets
um I'm here with my family
um I'm from Ellsworth thank you for
hearing me
um so our family has uh spent a lot of
time uh recreationally in the White
Mountains we live
um
right next to the border of the national
forest and
we've kind of looked into
um
drones and the and their future
essentially and our children's Futures
and if you even if you just look on you
know indeed a lot of the jobs in in you
know that are listed in science require
or you know ask for
knowledge of drone piloting so
it occurred to me at some point well we
should probably look into this and again
we spend a lot of our time hiking and
walking and you know playing in the in
the forest so this bill to me it looks
like a reasonable
um I mean and and so I'm a gardener I
like to be in the quiet I don't like to
you know
be in front of a computer so it is
something I'm really interested in
um you know watching
kind of evolve the um the use of of
drones in society
that's all any questions from members of
and the person with you this you want to
testify
well she was more interested in the dog
thing oh okay sorry I missed you
well thank you very much
uh official Lambert
in the New Hampshire D.O.T
the Department of Transportation
yes it's good afternoon
my name is Trisha Lambert and I'm the
administrator for the Bureau of
Aeronautics for the Department of
Transportation
for those of you who may not know much
about us for a very small within within
the department we have about six people
that run all the aviation matters within
the state under the Aeronautics acts
which is RSA 422
um
with that drones
which
most people call them and I have given
up because that's what we call them but
they're really unmanned aircraft
or Ant-Man aircraft system in fact the
last
um it's been about eight years I've
testified before many committees
regarding uas because it's new and
people are curious or they want to know
is it good is it bad we spent I spent
about three years just trying to get
definitions through which now are
currently in RSA 422.
Aviation is a wonderful safe
activity not for just transporting of
people and goods but also for
um
a industry like uas that children
truthfully are going to be taking part
in and it's not new anymore everybody
says oh it's this new industry it's not
new anymore and I think we're slowly
trying to adapt to them being in our
lives and how best to integrate them
um so we as the Department of
Transportation Bureau of Aeronautics we
are supportive and not only supportive
but we actually promote that
um we have drones ourselves
um we have everything from a small one
that can go through a
um
uh sorry we have we have small ones that
can do that can go in small areas all
the way up to a large
um one that we spoke about commercial
it's not just for the for making movies
we use it within the department we just
flew it out over Rye to look at the sea
wall and we had a gentleman there that
did that pretty much all day trying to
get data and we use that data and it's
fast it's safe and it
um
it's a lot less expensive than doing it
the regular the other way of surveying
way
so with that said
um with somewhat reluctance I am
opposing this bill but only because
um the technicalities and how it's
written
um right off the top it mentions that
you're it's a drone and under current
state statute it's a uas and I think
someone had asked the question about
well which ones are we talking about are
we talking about small large I believe
there are three definitions in there and
they relate back to the federal law and
that's to keep it so because it's it's
changing and we did that so that we
would always be lined up with the
federal law so that answers that's the
first issue
um
let me check my notes Here
so
the second the second note that I have
that um may be an issue is I I think
the airspace is is federal
um it's federally controlled
um people can debate that you know
whether you have space over your house
the FAA is still standing strong that
they own the airspace
so when you start getting into well you
can launch from here but you need to
know whether it has
an issue dealing with Canon mountain or
interferes
I'm not sure how you police that because
even if you didn't take off from that
spot
that
whether the parks let you or not
somebody could still fly in that space
because it's it's airspace for all
unless it's federally
um shut down
so I I sort of feel that falls into that
because I don't know how the park
service is going to be able to to
determine whether that is they can fly
there or not it's you know whether it's
going to be an issue
the
second part I think it's very clear that
the state has the ability or anybody who
owns property has the right to determine
whether they can take off it's take off
for landing and I think that's what the
intent of the bill is trying to do
um but again once you start saying where
they can and cannot fly I think that's
where it crosses over into Federal
preemption
there's a section on the aircraft
insurance
aircraft in the state of New Hampshire
it was repealed some time ago I
apologize I don't have the time frame
but it was before my time and I've been
here 23 years
there is no requirement for insurance
for an aircraft this is an aircraft this
is a registered aircraft with the
federal government and it has a number
so that makes it different than a moped
it makes it different than your car
because it is under the federal
jurisdiction
so however the state had the right to
determine whether they wanted to put
insurance and right now as it stands
there is none
privacy
I think this is an unintended slippery
slope in the sense that again I have
testified many times where
you know we have our phones and we
talked about I'm sure that it was went
through privacy issues and how do you
control the phone this is yet another
a piece of equipment that is very
similar to your phone in fact they can
hang the phone from it
and I believe privacy we feel privacy is
covered under RSA 644
currently as it speaks right now it
doesn't matter whether you're on a
ladder up to somebody's house or using a
drone or using your phone on the street
that is we feel is already covered for
that so we don't want drones to become
this special piece of equipment
like your phone so phones currently I
um
there's a section in here that talks
about charging fees to take off
you can charge a landing fee or takeoff
fee that's fine but the way it's written
it looks like it's being charged for the
flight and again you're charging someone
to fly
I believe that there's jurisdictional
possible jurisdictional issues there
whether it's
through between
State agencies or even potentially with
the FAA
so I I would say that because currently
right now the Department of
Transportation has its own fee structure
for all Aviation activities with the
hearings hearings board and all those
things and so I'm not sure whether that
would fall under that and again it's
carrying the jurisdiction over to the
parks which they can they can set their
own policy but not as it relates to the
flight aspect of it
that that is my take on it
um
I guess so on a smaller point is that
there are going to be uas's that have
emergency Landings and so there's a fee
structure as a part of that
um eight Pilots should have the right to
successfully have an emergency landing
put it where it needs to be in a safe
spot and not have the fear of a fine but
again that's that's a little bit
Crossing out of our jurisdiction but I
thought I'd make the point
think that's all I have if there's any
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question can you just repeat
the the point that you're trying to make
around privacy the unintended slippery
slope
there currently is a law
RSA 644 that addresses privacy
across the board
so
my experience in different
hearings is that if you you're now
adding in
it doesn't matter how you
um
impact someone's privacy whether you use
a ladder to climb up their house whether
using a phone it's another piece of
equipment and it falls under that
privacy statute whether if you're using
a drone and you're peeping in somebody's
to look at their mail
it would fall under 644 and that's what
we would we would
send the person back to the police to to
okay
uh anyone else have any questions on the
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question thanks for pointing
out uh the
the the Drone and the small unmanned
aircraft definition that's in 422. so
would you agree that
in this draft
um the use of drone and small on
unmanned aircraft is sufficient because
it's in 422 so in this draft
it would it would suffice I'm sorry it
was hard yeah I'm sorry that's okay
so thanks for pointing out that in 422
small unmanned aircraft is in fact
defined so in this draft it I mean do we
need to amend it so it refers to it
because I see in 422 that small unmanned
aircraft is defined and it's exactly
referred to in this draft it is referred
to I may
have anything they're using drones at
the top which tells you it's
it's the incorrect terminology which
could be confusing
all right thanks thank you Mr Sherman so
in line three it says a drone or small
unmanned aircraft and you mentioned that
in 422 it's defined so thank you for
that good work of four years of getting
those definitions in 422 23A
maybe in line three if we had a work
session it could be clarified a little
bit but I think you're correct it says a
drone or small unmanned aircraft which
is the same as RS RSA 420 to
27A there's I think there's three
different ones um yes the answer to your
question is yes I would reference back
to that so that that and I would remove
drone I would use UA whatever whatever
you're referencing and I would also
Define
um more clearly what drones we're using
know for a little tiny little tiny
little follow-up right so would you be
willing to help in a work session to
tweak that little language to maybe
really get it get it right and work with
your department to find it I'll even do
one better if there's ever anyone that
would like to see them operate
we have them we have like I said we have
them from the small to the large I think
that sometimes there's
not an understanding of what they are
um we have a gentleman that applies them
anyone else
seeing no one thing can I um I don't
know if I need to answer the
registration part I I think there was a
question earlier
would you like me to answer I don't know
representative was that yours it was
more about licensing yeah
So currently we do not license them in
the state they pay an FAA registration
we do register aircraft manned aircraft
along with the federal the federal have
a registration and we register so you we
can read we are currently not
registering at this time so
um where you we don't have access to the
federal database a lot of that is
because there are minors on that
database
okay
all right
that's it oh you got one more okay
Lamontagne
thank you for checking my question
um could you just explain a little bit
for me because I really don't know much
about drones and when you talk about
Aerospace
um and like where you take off and where
how how does that apply just anywhere
flying down the street I like where do
you distinguish between where you're in
public airspace and and when you're
invading
uh people's privacy if like where where
are people flying drones or unmanned
aircraft all right so that's a really
loaded question but I'll do my best so
um
the FAA for manned aircraft has always
had
different types of airspace I can go
through and list them all but with
requirements to be in certain airplanes
certain air space meaning you know you
have to talk to somebody or traffic
control so Manchester has controlled
what we call controlled airspace for the
uas when they came along
um FAA had to scramble to try to figure
out how to integrate these smaller
sometimes you can't see them
aircraft into the system and they have
done that
um I'll tell you at Concord airport
there's they call it Lance I don't I
can't I can't tell you exactly what all
the acronyms are but it they
um lay this over the airspace and they
have little grids and that can tell you
whether you can fly your drone whether
it's the first 200 feet first hundred
feet some go right to the zero down to
zero which means you can't fly it there
without
certain types of permissions
so that's how they're controlling that
as far as over your house that is a much
bigger conversation I think it's been
I can't recall the lawsuit but I think a
farmer had fought for that very reason
like I should have at least some amount
over my house
and I'm going to say that's to be
determined I think that that is still
being worked on as far as whether you
can have a drone if a drone is flying
right outside your window I probably
would use 644 and say someone's trying
to to look in my house because it's so
close
again that's to be determined depending
on that circumstance I'm not an attorney
and I'm certainly not law enforcement
did that answer question it's it's a
mixed bag
um but there is it's there's controlled
and uncontrolled airspace per the FAA it
answers a question thank you
uh no one else
uh thank you very much and the final
Paul Nickerson
in a
from the Audubon Society
thank you Mr chairman I see you could
read it this time yes that's right you'd
use the other very careful to write it
out I figured you used the other hand
that wouldn't help
yeah
you'll find my testimony this time I
won't be quite as opinionated as I was
about the dog issue
and as I go through it I think you'll
see why
I'm gonna confine my remarks to what we
do Audubon work on New Hampshire's
wildlife
and the effect both positive and
negative that drones may have on on
Wildlife first the positive
Wildlife biologists are increasingly
finding uses for drones such as to
monitor Wildlife populations in areas
difficult to access or count animals
that congregate in large groups like elk
bison and so forth but
when they do this is trained researchers
who are specifically monitoring the
animal's behavior and subject to
guidelines designed to avoid disturbance
to the subject animals and there's some
references here
fish and wildlife service and the forest
service both have provided guidelines
for drone use on their lands and they go
back several years
unfortunately a lot of recreational
users are not going to be aware that
such guidelines exist or are aware of
the presence of sensitive species near
trails
the negative
numerous instances of recreational
drones causing serious disturbance to
nesting Birds
drones have caused bald eagles to
abandon their nests in Arizona and have
caused Colony abandonment of elegant
turns and other shorebird species
drones are also being used to deter
birds from areas of human Wildlife
conflict which may be positive and may
we feel before the legislature grants
authorization for drone use within state
parks is a need for stakeholders
including Fish and Game to discuss risks
and potential need for regulations such
as should there be seasonal limitations
to avoid disturbing nesting birds or
wintering deer herds
should some parks be off limits due to
their proximity to sensitive species
such as bald eagles peregrine falcons
two of our big success stories by the
way in New Hampshire's I'm sure you know
both those species were going or almost
gone and now they've been restored
a great blue heron colonies
what guidelines should be promoted for
drone use in New Hampshire
what kinds of educational Outreach
should be undertaken and should permits
be required for use for drones and
Wildlife Research
in view of this the both the beneficial
and the detrimental effects we urge that
you refer hb434 to interim study until a
thoughtful discussion of these questions
among other topics that are likely to
arise can occur
any questions
of the committee
thank you very much
having no one there's no one else that's
having no more pink cards if someone
else wishes to speak
I will
go
I will uh
call in the hearing uh we all spill for
438 four
and also I will say
we have a meeting with the Des at 1 30
at 29
uh Haze and drive you're aware of that
and uh you know we're a 29 Hazen Drive
is you know where Hazen Drive is to
start with
just go get your yeah you can get your
plates there
right was that but it's not that in the
same not in the same spot it's 29 it's
not near uh uh H uh it's HHS
he hates the Health and Human Services
building
yeah it's right they're right right so
follow him
yeah you're gonna come running You're